we were a team despite our differences
in spite of the Terrible Things they'd
done we were still a
team that's not how to hire up saw it
though no the guys upstairs with their
perfectly pressed shirts for them we
were judged by our level of
expendability and they knew that our
next mission was a death
sentence one by one that thing took out
my team my
friends snapping their necks so quick
quick LLY and with such ease that no
sooner did I hear the scream they were
dead we had been used I'd been
used delivered as prey to the Predator a
plot that was sanctioned by the bosses
and approved with a blood red
stamp why did they do it I'm still
trying to figure that out maybe that's
something you can tell me after you hear
how these so-called scientific men left
us in the
cell and in the hands of SCP 17
3 for me it had been the best of times
before it became the worst of times the
best because I'd quickly risen through
the ranks of the facility the worse
because well I'll get to that I was
never the best student I finished high
school by the skin of my teeth and my
job prospects looked Bleak but I was
lucky I guess or at least I thought so
at the time you see I have an uncle Sig
freed who did some work for the
government I never actually knew what he
did did just that it was secretive work
I used to imagine he was some sort of
super spy so you can imagine how excited
I was when he found out I needed a job
and he offered to help me out I couldn't
believe it I always thought he hated me
I'd overheard him telling my parents
that I was a no good dead be but now
he'd had a change of heart and was
willing to take me under his wing what
would I get to do undercover
intelligence gathering International
assassinations just you wait he said
and that's how I found myself walking
into a sprawling futuristic looking
facility where they handed me a level
one security clearance card with big
bold letters that read janitor but I was
happy just the word security clearance
made me feel important and it beat
flipping
burgers I pushed mops turned off lights
fired up generators clocked in and
clocked
out but all that time they must have
been watching me grooming me waiting for
the day they could throw me to the
wolves I should have known I've always
been an Expendable kind of guy after a
few years I was called to an office and
there was a man in a plaid shirt and
kind of a tweed jacket that professors
wear he asked me do you have any idea
about what we actually do
here and to be honest I didn't I knew
that there were many parts of the
facility I couldn't enter I imagined
that down a maze of corridors were
weapons being built or prisoners being
interrogated ated but I had no idea
about the anomalies how could I before I
was told anything I had to sign a bunch
of forms there were so many I thought
I'd get to find out who really killed
JFK and while they didn't come out and
say it what I inferred was that if I
ever talk about what happens at the
facility to someone outside the facility
well let's just say it's not the kind of
thing they spell out on a piece of paper
but it involves padded cells and Rusty
tools I wasn't scared though I was part
of something big big something secret
and I left it so I signed my life away
with no hesitation soon after I was
introduced to my first anomaly the safe
class of
course they took me to an observation
room and from that room I could see into
another room with a sign on the wall
that read SCP 067 I just stood there
waiting for something to happen when in
walked another guy in a white lap coat
welcome to your first anomaly he said is
it okay if I hook you up to this heart
monitor we want to gauge your reaction
into what you see all I can see I told
him is an empty room with a table and
what looks like a pen on top of some
papers correct he said half smiling as
if I was some kind of idiot that's SCP
067 I thought about telling him that if
I needed years of training before I
could see a pen that I probably should
have taken that fast food job could have
been a shift manager by now then they
brought a young chimpanzee into the room
small enough to be harmless one of the
guys forced a pen into the scared shim's
hand and something strange happened it
started scribbling nonsense at first but
suddenly it was sketching and drawing
faster and faster I could catch glimpses
of words and images by the time they
dragged it out it was flailing around
like it was possessed that pen has power
said the man in the lab coat a power
whose Source or origin we don't fully
understand that's why we're here that's
why you are here one of the guys in the
other room held The Chimps drawing up to
the window it was a perfect sketch of
the Tower of London intricate and
Brilliant above the sketch was the title
Tower of London tutor period Circa 1541
the year Margaret pole the counts of
Salsbury lost her head on The Chopping
Block underneath that the chimp had
written pity she was no traitor take it
from me I was there they didn't need to
look at the heart rate monitor to see
that I was
shocked that was far from the only
anomaly I'd come into contact with and I
must have been doing something right
because in time I went from level one to
two to level three security clearance
and that that's when they made me a
containment specialist I won't bore you
with all the details but as you can
guess I dealt with the containment of
anomalies a lot of my time was spent
looking through small windows and cell
doors making sure that whatever was
inside was still inside and still in one
piece other times I worked with field
agents when anomalies were brought in a
transition period that the arrested
freaks didn't much like there was one
certain anomaly though that I was tasked
to oversee on many occasions I like to
think of it as my pet
but in hindsight I was its pet this was
SCP 173 something that was in what we
call the ukl class classification
meaning that we don't fully understand
it but know it is very
dangerous we know it's intelligent we
know it's unpredictable and we know it
will kill and for that reason there's
people tasked with containing it and
keeping an eye on it at all
times at first glance you wouldn't guess
just just how dangerous 173 is you
wouldn't think it's incredibly
intelligent in fact you'd think the
opposite that's because it's more or
less a walking slab of concrete and
rebar with stunted Limbs and traces of
spray paint that give the impression of
a Dopey face we have to enter itself
cell twice a week for cleaning duties it
leaves a disgusting foul smelling liquid
on the floor a reddish brown substance
that I can only describe as a mix of
blood and waste products where that
stuff comes from has remained a mystery
since we first contained it in 19
93 going into the cell was always a
three-man job because and this is maybe
the weirdest part about 173 it can't
move if human eyes are watching it
that's why you need at least two people
watching it at all times if you were in
the room watching 173 by yourself and
blinked you'd be dead before your eyes
open we don't know how it moves that
fast but in that fraction of a second
your neck is snapped so hard it's almost
like being decapitated I've seen the
videos to prove it all it took was a
sneeze he wasn't even finished getting
the rest of the auu out when there was a
Flash and his partner was left lying on
the ground his head twisted around the
wrong direction so you can understand
why we now require three men for any
time we must enter 173
cell then a few months ago I was told
that a long process would begin to train
and re-educate some future class D's
class D's are mostly prisoners with
lifelong sentences or those we've taken
from death row and given a new lease on
life we were apparently ly understaffed
so why not employ these men whose lives
had pretty much ended anyway that was
the rationale or at least that's what
they told me I was told to train them on
their new job mopping up 173s mess so
that me and the rest of the containment
Specialists could focus on more
important tasks they hadn't been through
the training I had seen what I had seen
But after showing them the video of 173
nearly taking off a man's head they were
more than willing to follow the rules
they understood not to Blink or turn
away or sneeze and that any lapse in
Focus could lead to a violent death so I
started to show them the ropes how we
move as a team into the cell and always
keep the others informed on what we're
doing 173 was always sitting in the
corner of a cell no expression on that
crude face but when we walked in its
cell I got the feeling it knew something
had changed I felt almost as if it was
communicating with me but I couldn't
tell what it was trying to say and then
it happened it was a Tuesday afternoon 3
days from the last time we' cleaned as
usual 173 had covered the floor with
that horrible liquid we headed into
clean my new team alert as always and
some of them cleaned While others kept
their eyes focused on the thing in the
corner things were going smoothly when
we heard a noise I knew very well it was
the sound of the cell door locking
someone must have screwed up hey guys
we're locked in here I shout it through
the interc nothing guys the damn door is
locked
nothing I lost it a bit open the door
will you
nothing my team looked at me the ones
not on eye contact Duty that is as if I
should know what to do hoping that this
had happened before and that there was
some kind of standard plan to deal with
it there wasn't we were always observed
when in the room and I knew that a
technician couldn't accidentally lock
the door it was impossible there were
protocols someone had done this on
purpose the four of us sat in the corner
of the room as far from 173 as possible
our eyes locked on it it didn't move an
inch as usual just stood staring at the
wall as it always did we stayed awake
through the night talking a little
holding on to the slim hope that
something had gone wrong but as night
turned to day again we all began to lose
hope we weren't sent here to clean we
were a test totally Expendable Lab Rats
that I wouldn't go down without a fight
we couldn't just stay up bre ever that
was a death sentence I suggested that
two of us stand one sit and rest and one
get some sleep we take shifts couple
hours on couple hours off maybe we could
show that we wouldn't give up they'd
have time to realize what they were
doing was insane call off the test and
come free us we made it through a couple
of shifts like this and it seemed like
we'd actually be able to make it another
day or two when everything went wrong it
was my turn to sit and rest when I heard
the worst possible noise snoring the con
next to me was sleeping quietly so it
must be one of the standers I glanced
over for just a split second and saw
both of them leaning against the cell
wall dozing at the same time I saw the
flash crack snap pop one after another
their necks were snapped I'm not sure
how it happened but I was standing again
staring at 173 who was now in the corner
dead bodies with their heads twisted
around piled up in front of it I
couldn't take it anymore I couldn't
stare at this thing forever I felt
myself giving up I lowered my head to
the ground and then finally broke my
gaze ready to
die and then nothing happened I slowly
raised my head back up and there it was
its hideous face inches away from mine
it was then that I understood what we'd
been containing what we'd
underestimated I felt it again like it
was telling me
something it was telling me to close my
eyes to sleep
so I did but as my eyes closed I didn't
see Darkness I saw 173 or something like
it but not in the cell I saw it outside
in the world standing over children
sleeping in the beds watching I saw them
hiding in the shadows staring out at
passers by then I realized they weren't
watching waiting to pounce no they were
hiding ing my eyes popped open as the
door opened and inrush six security
Personnel they took me outside jabbed my
leg with a syringe injecting me with
something as the world faded away
incident report time and date redacted
following the experimental forced
interaction with uclid class anomaly SCP
173 subject has ceased responding to
external stimuli and appears to have
taken on the traits and behaviors of the
anomaly subject now spends entire day
sitting in corner of cell staring at the
wall staff are advised to proceed with
caution when dealing with the subject as
the only Behavior they engage in is an
attempt to strangle anyone who enters
the cell no treatments have shown any
Effectiveness and subject will
unfortunately require incarceration
likely forever the fabric of our world
is littered with strange doorways if you
know where to look for them tears
portals
anomalies all leading to places and
plains Beyond human imagining and
understanding an SCP 23 37 otherwise
known as a door to another world
certainly fits that description
contained and kept at all times under
the watch of armed guards SCP 2317
appears to be a simple and unsuspecting
wooden door in its frame it hardly looks
like it requires such extreme
round-the-clock security or needs a
strange secretive ritual that the
foundation performs presumably to keep
the door closed but of course sometimes
the most interesting thing about a
closed doorway isn't isn't where it
leads it's what it keeps out even by the
foundation's already high standards the
requirements and regulations for
personnel who are assigned to SCP 2317
seem oddly specific psychological
testing is standard practice to work for
the foundation but an additional hurdle
that anyone has to clear before even
getting to Glimpse at this unassuming
wooden door is having a score of at
least 72 on the migr obedience
examination it is also mandatory that
Personnel assigned to maintaining it are
both unmarried with no children or next
of Ken as well as an unwavering
unquestioning loyalty to the foundation
pure devotion to its code and
objectives these may seem like strange
requirements after all SCP 2317 is just
a door isn't
it perhaps there's a reason that the
foundation keeps so much of the
information about SCP 2317 buried deep
under layers upon layers of security
with only the overseer Council privy to
the full details of its strange nature
knowledge as they say is power but maybe
knowing too much about whatever is
behind that door can prove deadly still
if SCP 237 is a door to another world an
alternate Dimension or parallel reality
it must be safe enough to visit after
all the foundation has been sending
Personnel in there on a regular basis
daily in fact according to the 05
Council this is done as part of a
procedure to maintain active containment
of something lurking beyond that old
wooden door frame but what could
possibly warrant such constant
maintenance and
surveillance in accordance with the
foundation's guidelines all staff are
required to rotate out of observing SCP
2317 after every 2 months and spend the
following third month in full
psychological counseling before they are
permitted to return to the containment
unit how housing the door to another
world it was after one of these
month-long periods of evaluation that a
foundation guard was informed that his
security clearance has been raised to
level three and that he'd been selected
for the duty of carrying out 220
Calabasas he knew the name instantly
this was the title given to the Daily
containment procedure that absolutely
had to be carried out the guard didn't
question these orders after all he'd
been selected precisely because of his
loyalty to the
foundation he did make one request to
his commanding officer however he wanted
to know what had happened to the last
guard that had performed the
procedure didn't make it out of
psychological evaluation the officer
replied not letting this affect his
dedication the guard was told to prepare
for procedure 220
Calabasas along with a fellow member of
foundation security Personnel the guard
was instructed to gather everything on a
strange list the first was a
pre-selected member of Class D personnel
specifically a convicted murderer class
D refers to disposable class Personnel
Expendable individuals recruited by the
foundation for the sole purpose of
testing
scps class D's were usually prison
inmates repurpose for SCP testing and
the one chosen for 220 Calabasas was no
exception serving multiple life
sentences for murders or at least that's
what the guard had been told a
foundation Personnel member instructed
him to refer to the class D solely as
the assistant from that point on next
the guard collected a live chicken an
obsidian edged knife a silver aspar and
aspersorium to be filled with 500 cc's
of holy water that have been blessed by
a priest of the abrahamic faith and
finally a 1 kiloton nuclear device which
according to instructions was only to be
detonated in the unlikely event of a
catastrophic containment failure in
other words The Last
Resort after following his instructions
to the letter and without question the
guard and his colleague were briefed the
foundation Personnel member informed
them that he'd be joining in leading
them in the procedure the staff member
also specified that henceforth he'd be
referred to as the celebrant until the
completion of 220 Calabasas the guard
was acutely aware of how specific these
instructions were but trusted in the
foundation knowing that if they wanted
this procedure performed a certain way
then it was in everyone's best interest
to carry out the orders to the letter
but what the celebrant then went on to
explain raised far more questions about
SCP
2317 and the nature of procedure 220
Calabasas the class D joining them
wasn't actually a Class D the assistant
as they were now referred to was in
reality another Foundation staff member
with a level four security clearance
specifically tailored to SCP
2317 every member of Staff entering
through SCP 2317 and taking an active
role in 22 calib bassis needed to be
informed that this assistant was not to
be harmed or treated as a member of
disposable class fighting back the
nagging question of why the foundation
would employ this subterfuge the guard
along with his fellow security officer
the celebrant and assistant prepared for
their departure through the door to
another world at solar noon when the sun
was highest over SCP
2317 solar noon chickens and holy water
this all seemed like an oddly occult
combination for the
foundation as they entered the old
wooden door Beyond lay a Barren salt
plane stretching out for kilometers in
every direction this alternate Dimension
according to the briefing was designated
SCP 2317 Prime the guard immediately
noticed a ring of Seven Pillars directly
ahead of the group as they entered each
of them bearing intricately detailed
Engravings unlike anything from any era
of ancient history procedure 220
calabases was carried out quickly but
carefully the guard watching as the
celebrant and assistant were careful not
to miss a step first the celebrant
scattered holy water into the center of
the pillars with the aspergum and
aspersorium looking down at his feet and
keeping a steady Pace as he stepped
counterclockwise around them the guard
watched intently as the celebrant
completed his circuit around the pillars
and turned to the assistant anointing
his head with Holy Water Seven Seals
seven rings seven Thrones for the
Scarlet King he said aloud the assistant
with the obsidian blade in his hand took
the chicken and dispatched it in
sacrifice letting its blood mix with the
holy water he then repeated the celebran
circuit in the opposite direction before
stepping into the center of the stone
pillars blood for the old gods water for
the new king the assistant recited
pouring the remaining mix of blood and
holy water over a patch of salt in the
middle of the Seven Pillars
even though he knew it wasn't his place
to question the foundation as the 220
calabases procedure took place the guard
couldn't help but wonder what all this
was for it seems so
ritualistic like something deeply
religious or even magical he never
bought into all that ult mumbo jumbo
even while working for the foundation
but he had learned not to question
anything even the strangest and most
inexplicable of
science little did he know know that
beneath his feet was an ancient and
unknowable horror a beast Chained and
lying in weight contained in a chamber
directly underneath the pillars sat an
impossibly large creature humanoid and
obese its body covered entirely in
Scales thicker than armor plating
branch-like horns protruded from its
jawless head pointing up to chains that
hung from the Seven Pillars above each
one hooked into the entity's back all
all but one of the chains was broken a
final withering shackle keeping the
devour of worlds in its underground
prison ever since 1894 BCE when arikian
Mystics imprisoned it the devour has
been waiting patiently for its
inevitable Freedom it knows as well as
the foundation that nothing can be done
to prevent the final chain from one day
breaking even procedure 220 calabases
won't keep the creature contained it's
nothing more than a smoke screen
an act designed to create an illusion of
active containment and maintain
Foundation morale until a permanent
solution can be devised to keep SCP
imprisoned of course if the guard had
known this it would have also explained
the need for a 1 kiloton nuclear device
as part of this stage ritual procedure
220 calabases had all the components to
trick everyone below the 05 Council
emulating religious and ult rituals R
The increased level of security
surrounding the procedure and its
purpose and telling staff that any
failure to correctly and completely
perform the 220 calabases procedure will
result in an XK Class end of the world
scenario all these elements work
together to conceal the truth that one
day the Devourer will escape and lay
waste to our
Dimension knowledge is power and maybe
knowing too much truly is deadly perhaps
if the guard had learned any of this
he'd have understood why his predecessor
never made it out of psychological
evaluation maybe if he had questioned
the purpose of procedure 220 calabases
he'd have learned the true nature of SCP
2317 and what that doorway kept out but
he was loyal to the foundation through
and through as the team finished
performing 220 Calabasas and returned
through the wooden door the guard took
one last glance over his shoulder at the
vast salt plane the entire Dimension was
calm silent but not peaceful it was
patient The Entity had waited centuries
for its time and now all it would take
was the breaking of this seventh and
final chain one day the door was closed
behind the guard as he the celebrant the
assistant and his fellow security
officers Ste back through their work
done and as far as they knew preventing
catastrophe for another day only the
foundation hups the overseer Council are
aware of the true danger posed by SCP
2317 and its sole
inhabitant current predictions are that
at some point within the next 30 Years
the Devourer of Worlds will be freed any
and all attempts to repair or recreate
the chains holding it in place have so
far failed as such the 05 Council has
elected to continue providing Foundation
personnel with the ignorant hope that
procedure 220 Calabasas is an effective
strategy for containment as we've said
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed door isn't where it leads
it's what it keeps out in the case of
SCP
2317 the unassuming wooden door holds at
Bay an ancient creature of Untold power
that will one day break free and wreck
havoc in our
Dimension nothing the foundation does
can prevent it or keep it contained
behind the door to another world and
only the overseer Council knows that any
and all efforts to do so are
futile with all that in mind we can only
hope that the doorway of SCP 2317 stays
closed at least for a little while
longer when an anomaly is first detected
by an SCP Foundation field agent it's up
to the foundation's mobile task forces
to tag and bag The Impossible entities
before before they can do any more harm
sometimes these retrievals are
uneventful other times not so much
especially when they're dealing with
brutal forces of nature like scp096
also known as the shy guy a creature
that from the very first interaction
with the foundation had a reputation for
being dangerous and needed to be feared
a series of vague sightings and
mysterious disappearances up in the
frosty mountains of the Yukon first
Sparks the foundation's interest when
they were certain that they had an
anomaly on their hands two retrieval
teams Zulu 9A and Zulu 9B were
dispatched to secure and contain the
entity Zulu 9A took the lead in a heavy
duty Chopper equipped with 50 caliber
g19 heavy machine guns and carrying an
at4 anti-tank launcher they were
prepared for anything or so they thought
as they established a visual on scp096
while two clicks away from the target
they couldn't get a clear line of sight
on the creature but it appeared to be
stationary docile and was making no
attempt to flee piece of cake right
little did they know that scp096 was
just looking away from them if it was
facing towards them it'd be a whole
different Horror Story as Zulu 9A were
about to find out the team landed their
helicopter next to the creature and were
shocked to see that it was completely
naked in spite of the Sub-Zero
temperatures all around them the
creature was unnaturally 10 as though it
had been starved for weeks with bone
white skin and unnaturally long limbs
the team guessed that the creature's
arms must have been at least 1.5 M long
but its dosal nature and insubstantial
body mass gave the impression that it
wouldn't prove too difficult to contain
that is until they saw its face Zulu 9's
Captain was the Lone Survivor of the
incident as he was lucky enough to be
looking away when the creature turned
towards his team the rest of the squad
ended up staring eye to eye with scps
096 and from that moment on wasn't
docile anymore the creature began to
whimper then cry then SOB uncontrollably
in a way that sounded eerily human this
Sudden Change in temperament startled
the rest of zulu 9A and they opened fire
on the creature under the hail of
gunfire scp096 entered a murderous
frenzy and began tearing into the
hapless Squad of soldiers while its
flesh and organs did seem to take damage
as a result of the barrage of 50 caliber
rounds from the helicopter mounted
machine guns its skeletal structure
remained intact and it continued its
Onslaught tearing the team limb from
limb even after they' blown practically
all the flesh from the creature the at4
anti-tank launcher proved equally
ineffective at stopping scp096 while it
was in attack mode and it was only after
slaughtering the entire team that it
returned to its docile State nobody
knows exactly what the creature did to
Zulu 9A after the gunfire started but no
trace of the team was left behind
Zulu 9B touched down soon after and with
a grave warning from the captain not to
look at the creature's face they were
finally able to subdue it a bag was
placed over scp096 his face which seemed
to soothe it enough to move it to a
nearby Foundation facility little did
they know they just obtained one of the
deadliest scps of all time and while it
may have been under lock and key for now
it seemed inevitable that it would get
out and cause more violence and Chaos
research and containment procedures for
the SCP 096 were put under the command
of Dr Dan a senior researcher at the
site it was his job to find out exactly
what this being was capable of the more
he tested the more he realized that they
were dealing with something truly
terrifying disposable d-class Personnel
were used to figure out exactly what it
was that caused the creature to enter
its Attack Mode just as it had during
the initial retrieval Mission scp096
went berserk when any of the attending
Personnel saw its face in this stage it
would enter a period per of considerable
and Unstoppable distress for 1 to 2
minutes covering its face and wailing
loudly when the period of distress ended
the creature would mercilessly Slaughter
every d-class that had seen its face and
just like with Zulu 9A no trace of their
bodies would be left behind Dr Den was
horrified and intrigued by this
phenomenon the creature killed anyone
that saw its face directly but could the
same be said for indirect depictions of
the creature's face such as images and
videos Dr Dan was desperate to find out
more d-class Personnel were brought in
to test this to frightening results Dr
Dan found that the creature did indeed
still enter Attack Mode when people saw
pictures and videos of scp096 his face
the creature seemed to have an innate
sense of when people were viewing these
representations even when it should have
had no conceivable way of knowing it
didn't matter how far away or how many
barriers were in place between the
viewer and the creature the attack mode
would still activate and once it did it
seemed as though nothing could stop the
creature from hunting down the one who
saw its face with all this new data
special containment procedures were
devised to keep the creature safely
under lock and key it cell was a 5 MX 5
MX 5 m airtight steel Cube fitted with
Advanced pressure sensors and Laser
detectors to ensure that scp096 remained
in its cell without risking anyone
having visual contact with the
creature's face all cameras and video
equipment were strictly forbidden and
weekly checks for any cracks or holes in
the containment cell were mandatory of
course none of this would stop the
Creature if anyone somehow saw its face
in order to solve that little problem Dr
Den would need to continue his
research to find a method of subverting
the creatur's deadly glance they needed
to know exactly what they were dealing
with but how could they when even a
glance at a photo or video of the being
meant certain death a potential solution
was proposed creating an artistic
representation of the creature's face
something that hadn't yet been attempted
but how would they achieve such a fee
simple they'd procure a d-class prisoner
with some artistic talent and they found
one who had been a tattoo artist before
becoming a foundation guinea pig Dr Dan
formulated an ingenious plan for keeping
this d-class alive for long enough to
accurately draw an image of scp096 his
face he would be placed in a bisphere
diving bell several kilometers
underwater and tens of kilometers away
from the containment cell where the SCP
was being held the d-class was made to
look at a photograph of the creature's
face and then replicate that image in a
pencil sketch Dr Dan first confirmed
that the creature's Attack Mode is only
activated by the creature's face by
having the d-class look at a series of
photos of the scp's body parts one by
one finally finishing with its face the
d-class began drawing and even remarked
on how creepy the scp's facial features
were despite not knowing the deadly
context meanwhile back in its
containment C scp096 sensed someone
viewing its face and entered its
inconsolable crying State followed by
its Attack Mode it broke out of
containment easily and began making a b
line for the d-class traversing the
miles between it and its prey the
d-class didn't know it as he locked the
finished drawing into a separate
autonomous submersible but he was
already dead as the drawing made its way
up to a researcher on the surface scp096
dived into the water and started
swimming down towards the artist minutes
later the BOS spere was breached and the
d-class was torn to shreds scp096 was
recaptured without issue by surface
recovery team foxtrot 303a and further
testing on the drawing showed that
artistic representations of SCP 0 96's
face were in fact harmless from this
experience we now know that the creature
has a gaunt face with totally white eyes
possibly indicating blindness and a
grossly extended jaw nevertheless Dr Den
was adamant that SC P 096 was too
dangerous to be left alive and requested
permission from the upper echelons of
the foundation to terminate the creature
by any means necessary however the
doctor's request would fall on deaf ears
until it all started with a seemingly
innocent image while it's now been
redacted for your safety the black Speck
inside the yellow circle was once a
minuscule image of scp096 taken
unknowingly in the 1990s by a
semi-professional mountaineer one day
they were looking at old photographs
when his eyes passed over the tiny Speck
without even noticing that he had seen
anything but scp096 noticed and began
entering its Attack Mode it tore through
its steel containment unit like tissue
paper causing the release of a nerve
agent that killed a number of attending
Foundation staff the monster then fled
the base and began pursuing its prey
with mobile task force to one in Hot
Pursuit Dr Alexy who was helping to
manage the site where the SCP was
contained was in dismay over the
situation Dr Dan was was out of the
country at the time trying to discover
more about the creatures Origins however
he did leave the mobile task force with
a new secret weapon against the
rampaging Shy Guy project scramble
scramble were state-of-the-art goggles
featuring a new technology created by Dr
Dan which using artistic Renditions of 0
96's facial features could detect and
scramble the features of scp096 into an
unrecognizable form preventing the
normally deadly effect of gazing upon
its face in theory this would allow MTF
t one to engage safely with 096 Once its
prey had been eliminated and bring it
back into containment but disaster
struck on two fronts first the prey in
question was located in a population
Center creating the potential for a huge
loss of life and the second bigger
problem was that the scramble technology
didn't work as stray pixels of the
creature's face would reach the eyes of
the task force before the internal micro
processor had time to scramble them the
mission turned into a death sentence as
scp096 slaughtered Ed almost the entire
task force as well as a number of
civilians in town including an infant
and its entire family it was a
Monumental disaster made even worse by a
final Revelation Dr Dan and Dr Alexi had
themselves facilitated the entire
Containment Breach and allowed the
resulting Massacre to happen with Dr Dan
hoping it would be enough motivation for
foundation command to Greenlight his
research into destroying the creature
anything that would give him the
opportunity to kill this thing would be
worth the Bloodshed his plan worked and
the SCP Foundation sought his way
approving his request to neutralize
scp096
however success comes at a cost for Dr
Dan once he figures out a way to finally
kill the creature though done in his
line of duty he himself will be
terminated by the foundation for his
crimes against humanity but considering
how much damage scp096 is capable of
causing if it ever got to a major
population Center or even worse was ever
caught on on camera and broadcast to a
worldwide audience the doctor himself
would likely deem his own death a
justifiable cost to this day the
foundation is researching ways to kill
the creature and they're still looking
for their Silver Bullet and the pressure
is on they hadn't known about the
seemingly innocent picture that sparked
the last containment breach the one
taken decades ago in which the shy guy
had only occupied four tiny pixels four
tiny pixels that resulted in multiple
innocent lives lost so be careful where
you look because who knows how many
other photos of the creature are lurking
up there photos with an innocent dot in
the background your eyes glance over it
not even noticing the little blip until
you hear a distant wailing that seems to
be getting closer and closer and closer
and then it's already too late every
time a bell rings an angel gets its
wings it's an iconic line from It's a
Wonderful Life and even even if you
don't believe in angels it is a pleasant
image after all angels are the
embodiment of goodness and light so an
angel getting its wings has to be a good
thing right well as anyone who's ever
eaten one too many Christmas cookies can
tell you it's possible to have too much
of a good thing even something that
sounds like the embodiment of all things
good in theory can become deadly when
taken to the extreme that is where SCP
469 also known as the many- wied angel
comes in this angel-like creature is
anything but innocent and in fact it has
been responsible for multiple deaths of
SCP Foundation Personnel during its
captivity SCP 469 may be deadly but it
is also undeniably beautiful in a
mysterious ethereal way when first seen
it appears to be nothing more than a
massive pile of pristine white feathers
like something out of a pillow
commercial the pile measures 24 ft in
diameter and weighs at least 2 tons
however like many of the entities
contained within the walls of the
foundation's countless containment sites
all is not as it seems with
469 what looks at first glance to be a
pile of feathers is in fact a dense
curled mass of giant wings the wings
vary in size from the tiny wingspan of a
sparrow to the Staggering 3.6 M wingspan
of the wandering Albatross the one thing
they have in common is their plumage
with each Wing being covered with the
same glossy white feathers the
foundation was able to perform a series
of x-rays on the mass of wings revealing
a skeletal structure beneath the
feathers like those of a bird the wings
bones are Hollow however they are
unnaturally soft and flexible allowing
for a range of motion that no known bird
possesses this accounts for the
curvature of the Wings and their ability
to coil tightly into each other the
x-ray also provided the first and only
recorded Glimpse at the creature hiding
underneath all the feathers at the
center of the layers upon layers of
wings is a humanoid creature curled into
a fetal position in defiance of the laws
of natural Anatomy every single wing
appears to be fused to this creature's
spine how would it be able to move under
the weight of these wings or even if it
could is as of yet unknown the First
Foundation Personnel lost to SCP 469
were d-class personnel d112 and
d624 who were sent in to investigate the
nature of the creature and attempt to
contact the humanoid entity identified
on the x-rays 112 and 624 entered the
room equipped with gloves and protective
eye gear as scientists watched the
situation unfold on a monitor on a video
feed No One expected much to come of the
encounter the working hypothesis was the
layers of feathers would simply be too
thick to get through without seriously
damaging the bones it would be a fairly
uneventful experiment or so they thought
112 approached SCP 469 first and
attempted to part a section of its
feathers with his hands as 624 stood
back and observed the moment his
fingertips touched the feathers a
rustling sound filled the room the
feathers began to quiver shaking as if
all waking up at once from a deep
Slumber suddenly in the blink of an eye
the hundreds and hundreds of wings
unfurled and pulled 112 into their
depths he was swept into a swirl of
feathers and within seconds he had
disappeared from view completely those
624 and the scientists watching on their
monitor could no longer see him they
could certainly hear him from the moment
the wings pulled him into the sea of
feathers one12 had begun to scream in
agony his screams persisted growing
louder and more desperate even as the
voice cracked and grew weak 624 stood
Frozen in place with fear and shock 624
was ordered to attempt to retrieve 112
from the feathers but made no move to do
so he simply stared at the feathers eyes
wide face pale as the pain shrieks of
his colleague bounced off the sterile
White Walls of the containment room a
guard called over the intercom
threatening to terminate 624 if he did
not attempt to remove 112 from SCP 469
grasp this warning seemed to shock 624
back into action and he made a run for
the center feathers arms up to protect
his face again the sound of rustling as
the feathers began to Quake the wings
unfurled once more and 624 did not even
have a chance to turn back before he was
pulled in to meet the same dismal fate
as the other declass his screams of pain
joined 112 as the scientists watching
over the monitor could do nothing to
help them as the two men cried out in
pain and horror from within their winged
prison something began to happen that
the scientists had never seen before the
feather started to shake again faster
than before four and at first the wings
appeared to be unfolding again upon
second look though it was clear they
hadn't moved there were simply more of
them now as the men continued to scream
more feathers appeared the wings
stretching out and elongating as new
Wings sprouted as if from nowhere SCP
469 appeared to be feeding on the sound
of their screams and using that energy
to expand it was only after several long
minutes when the screaming finally
stopped that the growth of the Wings did
two at this point the wing shifted again
expelling the bodies of 112 and 624 from
within its folds dropping them limply on
the ground though their deaths were
unfortunate the loss of 112 and 624 did
reveal some new information about SCP
469 first that it could grow and
apparently needed to feed on sounds in
order to do so second that it was deadly
to humans and most likely to other
living things as well autopsies of 112
and and 624 corpses would later reveal
exactly what happened to them and how
SCP 469 kills its prey though 469
feathers may look as though they would
be soft to the touch each feather is
actually made up of sharp barbs that are
capable of piercing clothing and skin
these barbs release a neurotoxin into
the system that activates every pain
receptor in the body of the victim the
neurotoxin present in these feathers has
not been identified anywhere else in
nature but is somewhat similar in
structure and function function to the
neurotoxins excreted by the cone snail
and in the bite of the blue ringed
octopus in addition to the pain inducing
neurotoxin the feathers also carry
several unidentified stimulant compounds
where the neurotoxin on its own would
induce enough pain for the affected
party to pass out almost immediately the
stimulants served to keep the victim
conscious SCP Foundation scientists
posit that this is so that 469 can get
as much noise in this case in the form
of Screams out of its pain as possible
and Achieve maximum growth before the
captive creature dies or goes into shock
further experiments confirm this Theory
and show that SCP 469 will react
similarly when exposed to any living
creature capable of making a sound and
experiencing pain not just humans
non-living matter though including dead
animals elicit no response from 469
additional experiments were then
undertaken that involved applying
various different sounds in order to
test their effect on SCP 469 growth
though it feeds on any sounds produced
in its presence it seems to respond most
strongly to musical sounds exhibiting a
particularly strong response to
classical music no sound elicits a
stronger reaction from this creature
however than the sound of ringing Bells
it is rumored that when a bell was rung
in the presence of 469 the humanoid at
the center of the feathers is said to
have moved for the first time on record
apparently whatever is at the center
appears to wake up and unfurl its wings
revealing itself but unfortunately all
security footage of this incident has
been White and the data has been
expunged from the record leaving the
creature's true form a mystery you may
be remembering that four members of
foundation Personnel on record were lost
to SCP 469 and that only two have been
mentioned so far the second pair of
casualties resulted when the foundation
attempted to terminate SCP 469 believing
that there was no more science specific
benefit to keeping it alive or at least
that the possible benefits did not
outweigh the risks it was ordered that
SCP 469 be terminated by any means
necessary two skilled Personnel Dr Jones
and Dr Smith were sent into the
containment facility in Hazmat gear
armed with several sharp instruments
they were to attempt to use these to cut
through the forest of feathers and soft
bones until they could reach the
humanoid at the center it was presumed
that once they did and the creature no
longer had the prote protection of its
poisonous feathers that it would be
relatively easy to kill they could not
have been more wrong Dr Jones approached
the dense cover of feathers with a pair
of sharpened gardening shears while Dr
Smith opted for a machete at first the
strategy appeared to be working Dr Jones
made several Quick Cuts with feathers
fluttering to the floor and sticking to
the Hazmat suit as Dr Smith slashed into
the feathers with his machete making
similarly promising progress however the
situation quickly took return for the
worst when Dr Jones dropped her shears
and let out a blood curdling scream the
feathers had taken a little longer to
get through the suit to her skin but
somehow they managed to find a way just
the same Smith grabbed Jones and
attempted to make a break for it but he
was too slow and far too close to the
feathers already the wings wrapped
around them and swallowed them both up
leaving the researchers outside helpless
to do anything but listen to their
screams and wait for them to go quiet
after after several minutes they finally
did and now larger SCP 469 had
officially claimed another two
Foundation Personnel obviously 469 could
not be terminated using any methods that
would place the responsible Personnel
within its grasp that was simply too
risky so the foundation selected a team
of d-class personnel to attempt to burn
the feathers with an array of
flamethrowers though the feathers were
vulnerable to Fire and began to Blacken
and disintegrate on contact the sound of
the Flames being expelled was loud
enough to feed SCP
469 its growth was so quick in response
to the noise that the fire could not
keep up with the amount of new feathers
and wings being produced by the same
time the flamethrowers ran out of
propellant 469 was the same size it had
been when they started other
terminations have been discussed
including the possibility of submerging
the entire creature in a highly
corrosive acid but so far this has not
yet been attempted whatever they end up
trying it is it's clear that nothing
that produces a significant amount of
noise will be able to kill
469 so where is it now what's become of
this perverse angel with the
never-ending Wings currently it is kept
in an airtight soundproof chamber where
nothing can trigger the growth of any
more wings so what is it an angel a
demon a twisted mutated bird of some
kind it is entirely possible that we
will never know but it's a wonderful
life at something right even by accident
every time a bell rings something
twisted and deadly though it may be gets
its wings it's 3 a.m. and the facility
is quiet office workers and
administrators roam the Halls security
officers stand at their posts clad in
advanced tactical armor and carrying
standard issue M4 carpin three
Foundation employees sit at flickering
monitors watching a live feed of footage
from the containment cell of the
infamous SCP 106 or as it's referred to
by all staff the old man no found
Foundation Personnel are permitted to
travel within 60 ft of the cell for
security reasons and nobody is permitted
to physically interact with the anomaly
without the approval of 2/3 of 05
command the observer's eyes itch and
Sting from hours of unending blue light
exposure but they can't look away the
old man is Crafty he might have the
insatiable blood lust of a hungry great
white shark but he's not mindless he's a
calculating Predator more sadistic than
the worst human serial killer and he's
always searching for the next
opportunity according to the foundation
records he's been active since at least
World War II and it's estimated that he
has hundreds if not thousands of victims
to his name and many of those made
simple but extremely foolish mistakes of
underestimating him after all it only
takes a few seconds of inattentiveness
in the briefest moment of distraction to
give him the window he needs to do what
you ask oh don't worry you'll find out
just like they did the old man has his
nickname for a reason most of the time
he really does look exactly like that an
old man or more specifically an old
man's decaying corpse his body covered
in Rotten Dark grayish black flesh that
looks like putrid meat though the
creature has been observed being able to
change shape the rot seems to run too
deep for the old man to ever hide it
Foundation employees that have observed
SCP 106 for extended periods of time
have reported seeing it assume the form
of grinning decayed children and women
whose rotted flesh barely hangs on their
creaking bones just seeing the images
through a video feed is enough to cause
a lifetime of insomnia and other
sleeping issues
still they have a job to do and the
cameras remain fixed on the old man he's
been completely motionless for 3 months
just sitting there like a budhist monk
in deep meditation a office might see
this period of inactivity as a cause for
celebration but those with experience
know that this is merely the Calm before
the storm SCP 106 can remain in a
dormant state for months at a time
described by the foundation scientists
as a lulling state it's believed that
the Old Man simply waiting for its capts
to get soft make a mistake or simply
have a momentary laugh laps in
concentration which is all it needs to
make its move it had happened so many
times before and it was about to happen
again one of The Observers must have
felt an overwhelming wave of anxiety as
he saw the creature ever so slightly
twitch just a tiny quiver in the
shoulder muscles but that was enough to
tell the Observer that their day had
just taken a terrifying turn he grabbed
the emergency phone fixed to his desk
and practically screamed into the
receiver that 106 is moving that they
need a Tactical Team stat but it was
already too late he and the other two
observers stared into the monitors with
their mouths of gape as a gooey
rust-like substance began to pull around
the creature on the floor of its cell
slowly the creature craned its withered
neck around its face was fixed into a
broad yellow Toth lipless grin its eyes
had the kind of dull flat malice of an
underwater Predator it looked directly
into the camera directly at them and
smiled The Observers knew this was bad
really really bad with what they could
have sworn was a little nod the old man
began sinking into the rust puddle had
made on the ground beneath it until it
had disappeared entirely SCP 106 is
capable of phasing through any solid
surface with ease making it one of the
hardest entities to reliably contain and
earning it a spot on the dreaded keer
class reserved for the anomalies that
are complete nightmares to keep locked
up through the years of costly research
and deadly trial and error the
foundation would later devise ways of at
least slowing the creature down it's
shown to have an aversion to lead highly
complex or random physical structures
and intense bright light none of these
cause harm to the creature as far as we
know literally nothing can but they'll
at least buy you some precious extra
seconds with which to at least try an
escape seconds the three observers
didn't have one of them grabbed an
emergency line again and barked into it
that they lost visual on the anomaly
just then The Observers heard a faint
crackling sound behind them and the
hissing of a chemical burn they turned
in horror to see a huge Rusty burn mark
expanding across the wall right next to
the door which was their only Escape
Route they backed it as far away from
the door as they could as a rotten hand
began reaching out of the mass of
corrosive black sludge followed by the
grinning face of SCP 106 ready to have
some fun meanwhile two heavily armed
security officers agents Goodwin and
Resnik came charging down the corridor
toward the observation rooms it become a
bleak slogan during SCP 106 Escape
attempts that all you need to do is
follow the screams and that MTO was
proven true that night because awful
things were happening to the observation
Personnel they were certainly screaming
about it of course even with the
top-of-the-line Firearms there was
little they could do to harm the
rampaging old man he seemed immune to
all forms of physical damage all they
could hope to do was keep the thing
distracted until the scientists and
containment Specialists finished the
preparations to lure him back into his
containment cell goodwi surged forward
while Resnick covered his six vigilance
was key as unlike a standard human
combatant SCP 106 could attack from
literally any angle including above or
below physical obstacles were irrelevant
to him and no no cover was safe the
hardened security officers could see the
burn mark on the wall of the observation
room as they approached SCP 106 was
perpetually coed in a thick black mucus
with powerful corrosive properties that
left any surfaces it touched permanently
marked Foundation scientists speculated
that this mucus served as a kind of pre-
digestive substance that tenderizes meat
and Bone alike but to what purpose this
serves is a mystery as the old man has
never been observed eating it's
postulated that the only purpose is
causing additional pain Goodwin and
Resnik knew to treat this hissing sludge
as a Potential Threat as the corrosive
properties would remain active for as
much as 6 hours before finally fizzling
out the two officers shared a quiet nod
before Goodwin breached the observation
room door with a hard kick the two of
them searched inside guns at the ready
in their time working at the foundation
they'd seen some truly horrific sights
from the mutilation of d-class personnel
typically death row prison inmates
brought in for use as SCP guinea pigs to
the violence and Mayhem of a Containment
Breach with the there was nothing in
their past that would ever make the
horrifying sight they saw in the
observation room that night feel normal
all three observers were dead almost
nothing remained of two of them and the
third while still intact no longer
looked human he looked like he'd somehow
been dead a hundred years in the brief
period that the old man had been free
his skin was gray and completely dried
out and his mouth was locked into a
Perpetual scream it was a massacre but
there was no sign of the old man Goodwin
grabbed his radio and whispered this is
Goodwin in observation room 6 requesting
immediate backup we have no idea where
this thing but his sentence was cut off
by a sudden scream from agent Resnik SCP
Foundation security officers are as
tough as Nails the best of the best you
might say recruited from the top
military organizations in the world so
hearing one of them scream in Fright is
a rare if not impossible occurrence but
even they were forced to yell out in
fear when they looked up to see the old
man standing on the ceiling grinning
down at them Resnik raised his M4 and
shot a three- round burst at Center Mass
SCP 10 six didn't care even under
sustained gunfire from the two security
officers it didn't Flinch the Old Man
simply reached down and snatched agent
Resnik from the ground like it was
picking an apple from a tree the old man
held Resnik in one hand and pounded its
other rotten fist into the agent's body
breaking all of his bones Resnik
screamed for his partner to help him but
there was no time before goodwind could
do anything SCP 106 began receding back
into another slimy burn mark on the wall
only this time he was taking his
screaming victim with him agent ni gave
one more horrified scream before he was
pulled backward into the inky Darkness
leaving the room silent except for the
burning hiss of the corrosive goo left
behind you might think this would be the
end of it but no for poor agent Resnik
the worst was yet to come he was being
dragged into what the SCP Foundation
scientists refer to as the old man's
pocket Dimension a miniature layer of
reality within our own where the
malicious SCP is essentially a cruel all
powerful God according to witness
reports extracted from Vic victims who
were taken to this little nightmare
realm the dimension resembles a series
of twisting endless corridors where the
old man stalks and tortures and captured
victims to the breaking point
manipulating space and time to his own
sadistic ends on rare occasions the SCP
will even release its victims just for
the joy of hunting capturing and
torturing them all over again while
agent Resnik was learning the true
meaning of Terror containment
Specialists were mobilizing in itself
cell preparing the one known tried and
true method of luring the old man back
tempting it with the prospect of causing
even more suffering in order to do this
Foundation Personnel take one of the
aforementioned class D personnel and
begin inducing extreme pain by breaking
a major bone or slicing a tendon every
20 minutes the victim's agonizing
screams are then played over the
facility's intercom acting as bait for
the pain loving old man the screams echo
through the facility's otherwise silent
Halls as the mutilated corpse of agent
Resnik falls from a new Scorch mark on
the ceiling the old man can hear the
sounds of suffering ringing out through
the air around him and he can barely
contain his excitement over the prospect
of a new play thing the snapped femurs
the torn to killes tendons it was all
too good to miss having had its Twisted
fun with the security officers and
observers SCP 106 wandered back to its
containment cell where a new screaming
victim awaited the other security
officers containment Specialists and
scientists evacuated the area leaving
the old man alone with his prey while
the unfortunate class D was left to his
fate the the rest of the staff commenced
cleanup procedures which mainly involve
wiping the brown and black mucus from
the walls it would probably be at least
another month before anything like this
happened again and new Personnel would
be transferred over to the facility to
replace the Fallen all in all just
another night at the SCP Foundation cast
your mind back to the height of the Cold
War the ever accelerating nuclear arms
race brought us closer than ever before
to making the nightmare of nuclear
Armageddon a terrifying reality the two
main parties in this conflict are the
United States and Soviet Union each
amassing huge amounts of nuclear
warheads and jumping on any available
Advantage they can over their enemies
what you may not know is that in order
to detect an impending attack from the
United States the Soviets developed what
would become known to the West as the
dead hand but this experimental piece of
technology also had another name SCP
1984 it is no secret that the Soviet
Union feared the threat of US nuclear
strikes and Invasion just as much as the
US feared an attack from them so SCP
1984 was created to act as a deterrence
mechanism specifically against secure
second strikes secure second strikes
were both a deterrent and overwhelming
concern during the Cold War referring to
a country's ability after suffering an
initial nuclear attack to still
retaliate firing on their enemy and
causing Untold damage with their own
arsenal of nuclear weapons the Soviet
Union knew that any action they made
that could be perceived as an attack on
United States soil would be threatened
with nuclear retaliation and that if
they fired First America would return
fire and potentially annihilate them
with a second strike SCP 1984 was to be
an automated system that would activate
in response to the destruction of the
soviet's main command and control
structure given that the Dead Hand was
created during the80s you might be
forgiven for expecting a nuclear
detection system built at this point in
history to consist of various sensors
connected to a computer network but you
have also probably already realized that
if this was the case then the foundation
wouldn't be so interested in it in
actuality SCP 1984 is a fully autonomous
entity rather than a network of sensors
for detecting incoming nuclear strikes
or a computer capable of initiating a
second strike perhaps what makes the
foundation more interested in the Dead
Hand is that it is both self aware and
links simultaneously to every single one
of Russia's nuclear launch sites not
only this but scp1 1984 also has direct
access to every single one of the atomic
weapons stockpiled by the Soviet Union
during the Cold War and is capable of
launching intercontinental ballistic
missiles at a moment's notice in short
SCP 1984 could very easily and
horrifyingly quickly trigger an allout
nuclear war resulting in the extinction
of all life on Earth no wonder the
foundation considers the dead hands such
a massive threat SCP 1984 itself
actually consists of the preserved
remains of a Russian soldier by the name
of Sergeant morat chernikov who was
killed during the Soviet Afghan war in
1982 most of the official documentation
of chernov's existence has been expunged
by the Russian Federation and he is only
referred to in fragmented documents
recovered by the foundation that refer
to a project December these remains
serve as the location of a semi-
sentient Consciousness that has been
classified as SCP
19841 when it remains dormant and is not
interfered with SCP
19841 has the ability to receive and
process any signal broadcast to it and
is able to decipher information combined
in any signal it picks up however when
global Military tensions start de climb
especially when those tensions affect
the Russian Federation or what were once
the satellite states of the former
Soviet Union The Entity begins to
manifest itself in the physical world
and usually in various strange and
different ways SCP
19841 has been known to appear in the
real world in forms such as a humanoid
outline or a bright red Spectre taking
the shape of a child with its legs cut
off regardless of which shape it appears
in it is when the Dead Hand manifests in
a more physical form that the wider
scope of its abilities become clear as
mentioned previously it can influence
and even launch nuclear weapons
overriding their command systems and
bypassing launch sequences after
appearing fully scp1
19841 will travel at speeds of up to 140
km an hour directly to the nearest
military installation capable of
launching intercontinental ballistic
missiles once it reaches its destination
scp1
19841 will immediately attempt to
override the necessary systems to
initiate a launch after firing missiles
at their predetermined targets SCP
1984-1985 is highly aggressive and will
lethally defend itself against anyone
that it observes trying to interfere
with it or stop it from causing a new
nuclear launch the entity has displayed
the ability to disrupt the nervous
system causing excruciating pain and
debilitating damage to human beings its
only known weakness if any is a
susceptibility to microwave radiation
although exposure to this does not seem
to cause any lasting damage to SCP 1984
instead only temporarily disorienting
its physical form as for the origins of
SCP 1984 the Soviet Union's official
liaison with the SCP Foundation offered
some clarity on this ironically during
early 1984 the liaison a doctor named
Sergey described information regarding
the Dead Hand as being of grave
importance to the continued survival of
the human race seeing as he was
referring to an enemy that could
single-handedly launch the Soviet
Union's entire nuclear Arsenal he
certainly had a point a top secet
Conference was held in sevo between the
foundation's 05 Council and officials
from both the USSR and the United States
using the 1984 Winter Olympics as cover
avoiding too many questions about
several Nations high- ranking State
officials being in the same place at
once the 05 Council was then given full
in-depth information about the Dead Hand
something they had previously assumed
was a more conventional form of nuclear
deterrence SCP 1984 was far more and
worse far out of the control of the
Russian government it was revealed that
the entity had been designated outside
side the original specifications given
to those who developed it initially the
Soviets had intended for the Dead Hand
to be solely used as a secure second
strike response if the leaders of the
Soviet Union were killed SCP 1984 would
react in kind to Russia's enemies
launching back all of the ussr's nuclear
missiles in retaliation this is more
likely where the Dead Hand nickname
comes from hearkening to the idea of a
dead man's switch picture that you had
been mortally wounded by a your worst
enemy shot in the stomach and laying on
the ground rapidly bleeding out you know
that there is no chance you will survive
but you cannot afford to let your enemy
get away what they don't know is that
you rigged the entire building around
you both with explosives with your dying
breath you activate the Detonator
assuring your own and your enemies
Mutual destruction Kaboom then curtains
for both of you the pressing issue and
the reason this secret Summit between
the USSR USA and SCP Foundation was held
was that SCP 1984 was no longer
interested in just waiting for Russia to
be attacked and only reacting after the
fact instead the entity's physical form
was trying to preemptively strike at the
enemies of the motherland attempting to
activate nuclear launches and send
Atomic weapons to destroy the United
States France West Germany and the
People's Republic of China in other
words the Dead Hand was eager to get a
head start at causing total nuclear
Annihilation not to mention potentially
killing millions and reducing Target
countries to little more than a radiated
craters a wash with deadly nuclear
fallout both the Soviet Union and the
United States begged the SCP Foundation
to intervene and contain SCP 1984 and
under the direction of the 05 Council
they stepped in to take direct control
of the situation establishing new
containment procedures in the hopes of
keeping SCP 1984 from as many launch
buttons as it could find the embalmed
remains that seemed to create the
manifestations of the dead-and entity
were held securely in an armed
containment complex near verco yank part
of the Saka Republic within the Russian
Federation SCP 1984 was placed within a
standard humanoid containment cell which
was itself held within a faraday cage a
type of enclosure constructed with or
covered in conductive material designed
to block electromagnetic fields this was
done to block any external broadcast
signals from reaching SCP 1984 and thus
causing it to manifest its other form if
it learned of an impending attack on
Russia even a fictional one perhaps as a
part of a television broadcast as part
of the dead hands Containment all
signals broadcast near its cage are to
be monitored and only broadcasts
featuring doctor information would reach
the entity thankfully to the work of the
SCP foundation's information control
team SCP 1984 is drip fed a stream of
care F fabricated information using
on-site equipment and Facilities a team
of military historians economists actors
and Soviet media Specialists the
information control team have created an
ongoing narrative wherein the Cold War
never ended through falsified radio and
television broadcast made to look like
era appropriated news organizations they
managed to keep SCP 1984 convinced that
the nuclear stalemate between the Soviet
Union and United States is still on
going unfortunately sometimes
information from The Real World is able
to bleed through an incident involving
SCP 1984 occurred on August 8th 1984 and
almost brought forth a fullscale nuclear
war while preparing for a campaign
speech the 40th President of the United
States Ronald Reagan uttered the
following joke I'm pleased to tell you
today that I've signed legislation that
will Outlaw Russia forever we begin
bombing in 5 minutes naturally thousands
of media Outlets reported on this but
signals of those broadcasts including
recordings of the president's remark
made their way to SCP 1984 Foundation
researchers were both unsure of how
these Transmissions breed the faray cage
surrounding the Dead Hand and were
unable to prevent what happened next
hearing what it could only assume was a
genuine declaration of war the
manifestation of the SCP
19841 entity happened immediately after
Reagan's words reached its containment
Cent cell this time the entity appeared
as a semi-transparent woman withered and
blue wearing traditional pashton dress
armed Personnel guarding scp1 1984's
cage engaged The Entity causing it to
retaliate lashing out and attacking any
that stood in its way one captain and
two privates that suffered the brunt of
SCP 1984's offensive capabilities began
bleeding heavily from their ears seizing
violently most gruesomely of all a
liquid leaked from their eyes and nose
believe belied to have been cerebros
spinal fluid while armed Personnel
attempted to use microwave emitting
Weaponry to slow The Entity down the
information control team was frantically
trying to record a new falsified
broadcast in the hopes that SCP 1984
would cease its hostilities and the
entity would dissipate before it was
able to travel at high speed to any
nearby Soviet nuclear facilities and
begin bombarding the United States their
first attempt to record a new broadcast
that would result in a cessation of SCP
P 1984 Slaughter of its guards was
interrupted when a nearby wall collapsed
desperate to recontain the creature the
information control team tried to film
the broadcast a second time and
succeeded although one of the actors
portraying a newsreader suffered a
stroke and had to be edited out to
convince the Dead Hand of its supposed
authenticity What followed was a short
news clip clarifying that Russia's poit
Bureau was in on President Reagan's joke
including old footage of the ussr's
general secretary Constantine shern
confirming that the Soviet Union's
nuclear forces were not on high alert
miraculously after 15 more minutes of
sustained fighting with guards SCP
1984's physical manifestation began to
disappear gradually dematerializing
while it seemed to attack with far less
intensity eventually containment was
reestablished at the cost of the deaths
of 17 members of foundation staff both
guards and researchers a further Aid
however suffered traumatic brain
injuries that left them all permanently
disabled the one upside is that this
incident Remains the only time SCP 1984
has ever breached its containments and
caused harm to others and considering
that it could very well have launched
Russia's nuclear Arsenal the casualties
could easily have been much higher so
remember folks don't joke about nuclear
weapons especially if you're the
president you never know what anomalies
lurking in the bodies of dead Russian
soldiers might be listening and if they
are you'd better hope they have a sense
of humor the young girl stood silently
in a room full of corpses staring off
into the distance she was in a trance
seemingly unaware of the Carnage that
had just unfolded around her some of the
men were shot or stabbed or beaten
others had no apparent cause of death
whatsoever but the young girl was
unscathed she was wearing a yellow
summer dress and looked like she
couldn't have been more than 3 years old
she awoke from her trance still paying
no heed to the violence in the room and
left this is the story of SCP
053 the young girl her strange and
terrifying life before containment her
thrilling capture and the part she
played in one of the most dangerous SCP
Foundation cross tests of all time she
had no name the young girl could never
spend enough time around found someone
to be given one it was her terrible cage
that she could never stay in one place
for too long or something truly awful
would happen to everyone around her
she'd been drifting for years but never
grew to look older than a child her
memories were long but formless divided
mostly into 10-minute increments the
young girl kept on moving it was all she
could do in 1993 when the young girl had
already been alive for a very long time
she found herself in Illinois after days
of trekking on the roadside she would
scavenge what little food she needed
from the trash and drink from lakes
rivers or even puddles when she needed
to deep down the young girl knew that if
she ever grew hungry or thirsty she
would not die in her travels the young
girl had managed to scrunch together a
few dollars and though she knew her
contact with people had to be limited
there was one thing she wanted that felt
worth the risk a candy bar it' been a
long time since she tasted chocolate and
she found the idea of tasting it again
too enticing to resist when she reached
Chicago she entered a small corner store
with her handful of dollars selected a
candy bar from the rack and approached
the counter for reasons even she didn't
fully understand she kept her eyes down
as she placed the money on the counter
you see SCP 053 was always a special
child as we breathe briefly mentioned
earlier you might even say she was
cursed whenever she was around other
people for too long Terrible Things
tended to happen unspeakable things and
as a component of this strange
unexplainable curse or perhaps as a
means of keeping her safe from it the
young girl was doomed to never
understand the nature of her predicament
it was like there was a mental wall
between her and the horrors her presence
could cause all she knew was that it was
best to avoid eye contact stay away from
large groups of people at all costs and
never spend any longer than 10 minutes
around anyone ever that's why as she
waited for her chocolate bar at the cash
register she kept her head down and
waited to go the cashier looked Upon
This Strange girl with apparent concern
it' been a slow day all in all a few
listless patrons milled around the store
window shopping his brain was
practically on autopilot until he saw
saw this child she looked filthy in a
disheveled dress and was totally alone
what on Earth had happened to this child
the more he looked at her the more he
sensed a creepy Vibe exuding from her
something about this girl was wrong he
spoke softly to her introducing himself
as miles and asking her where her mommy
and daddy were the young girl hesitated
for just a few seconds too long for his
liking before simply saying that this
were at home any parent who'd left their
three-year-old kid just wander around
the south side of Chicago alone was
either crazy neglectful or both he asked
her politely to remain in the store
while he gave the police a quick call
he'd even let her have the candy bar for
free while she waited immediately the
little girl became uncomfortable she had
already been in here for a few minutes
now and while miles called the police he
expected her to wait around even
longer again she couldn't even tell you
why why she knew waiting around like
this would be so dangerous but she had a
nagging instinctual awareness that she
needed to get out around the store the
few patrons still inside started to get
a strange feeling like someone was
watching them soon what seemed like mild
paranoia was quickly becoming white hot
anger pure rage they felt almost like
they had to kill someone but not just
anyone someone particular
they had to kill the little girl it
wasn't long until the police arrived two
officers holiday and dwit entered to
collect the Apparently neglected little
girl it was a story they'd sadly heard
all too often a tragically common
occurrence in the big city when the two
of them approached the young girl she
was looking down at the ground they
tried to speak to her but she was
unresponsive miles looked on concerned
but deep down he felt the same bizarre
progression all the other store goers
were feeling confusion irritability and
finally violent rage the corner store
was a powder gig all it needed now was a
spark and that spark came when officer
holiday reached down and took the young
girl by the arm his bare skin touched
hers and it was all over the cop
twitched his mind washed out in
murderous Insanity as he reached for his
sidearm officer dwit opened his mouth to
protest but he didn't manage to get a
syllable out before holiday turned and
shot him in a fraction of a second the
quiet Corner Store exploded into a
violent blood bath as the patrons and
cops slaughtered each other all the
while the young girl just stood there in
the trance everyone was dead within
minutes except miles and the young girl
he shakily rose to his feet his mind
carved out by Madness and reach for
officer holiday's discarded pistol
outside of the store the young girl
appeared walking out as if nothing had
happened inside miles's body was
sprawled over the counter clutching his
chest as if his heart had just exploded
this was the true nature of the young
girl's curse anyone who meets her eye
touches her skin or spends over 10
minutes around her is destined to slip
into a state of murderous Insanity
they'll go into a kill crazy frenzy and
attack anyone around them until all that
is left is them and the young girl at
which point they'll try to kill her too
but the mere Act of attempting to kill
her is also fatal killing its victims
with a massive heart attack or a seizure
the second part of the girl's curse is
that she herself can never die she keeps
coming back unknowingly causing more
misery and death along the way until of
course a certain secret organization
took notice that night the young girl
sat in the cavernous interior of a local
abandoned warehouse quietly eating her
hard-earned candy bar suddenly she heard
a quiet crack in the distance she tried
to move her left arm but found it was
numb she could barely move it the girl
turned her head and saw a tranquilizer
dart sticking out of her skin
instinctively she got up and began to
run limping as her left leg started to
lose all feeling too suddenly she was
surrounded by footsteps as masked men in
swat uniforms emerged out of the
darkness on all sides Minds the last
thing she remembered before slipping out
of Consciousness was a blindfold being
pulled over her eyes and Tiny metal
handcuffs clasping over her wrists when
she woke up she was in the nicest room
she had slept in in years it was 16 ft
by 16 ft with toys books and games
standing across the room from her was a
stranger in a full hazmat suit connected
to a long steel cable leading out of the
room he spoke calmly and politely a
timer on his wrist counted down from 10
minutes The Stranger explained to the
young girl that they would be taking
care of her now and would provide her
with all the toys and games and treats
she wanted provided she cooperated and
submitted willingly to some tests
compared to living out on the streets
with no food or Comfort this seemed like
an excellent
compromise she would live in what seemed
like luxury and every so often she'd be
taken to a testing room with a stranger
in an orange
jumpsuit after a few minutes of waiting
The Stranger would inevitably go feral
and attempt to kill her and then always
die in the process The Strangers in the
hazmat suits told her that all of these
tests were helping them learn extremely
valuable things about her and that soon
they'd have a very special job for her
it would be a wonderful surprise it was
the spring of 1994 that the young girl
now officially designated SCP 053
finally received her special Mission
several strangers in full hazmat suits
wielding rifles escorted her out of her
usual bedroom she asked where she was
being taken and was told she was going
to meet a new friend she was taken to
one of the recreational testing rooms
and pushed inside out in front of her
she saw something terrifying a giant
reptilian creature she retreated from it
instinctually hiding behind a chair in
the containment area the giant reptile
didn't move it just sat there eventually
she plucked up the courage to go and
touch the creature before retreating
again no reaction little by little the
young girl gained confidence and
continued to approach and Pat the
creature it exhaled through its huge
nostrils and the young girl literally
jumped for joy in her Amusement she
began to play with the docile monster
hugging it even drawing on it with a
crayon The Observers were truly baffled
what the young girl didn't know was that
she was playing with SCP 682 one of the
most hateful and aggressive anomalies
under the foundation's watchful eye and
yet in her presence the creature was
like an overgrown puppy dog after the
test phase the young girl was removed
from the hard tokill reptiles presence
immediately causing the creature to
become violent and murderous once again
after being separated from her strange
new friend the young girl was seen
crying for several minutes a according
to all accounts the young girl is eager
to see her friend again someday though
considering the reptile killed several
guards after their separation the
foundation isn't eager to Grant her that
wish SCP 053 was classified as uclid and
continues to be held in containment with
her toys books and games rotated out on
a regular basis seeing as she shows no
sign of Aging this ongoing containment
is likely to be the sad strange fate of
the young girl an anomaly that never
wanted to hurt anyone but an important
and cruel reminder that what we want
doesn't always influence the world in
the way we want one of the primary aims
of the SCP Foundation is to contain the
anomalies that they discover secure
contain protect is their mission
statement after all however there are
some forces so unknowable and malevolent
that there is no way to truly contain
them SCP 42
5 is one such Force very little is known
about SCP
4205 even compared to other scps many of
which are mysterious by their very
nature we do not know what it is we do
not know what it wants and we do not
have any meaningful way to stop it the
best that can be done to protect
yourself from it is to implement the few
known preventative measures available
and pray that it doesn't set its sights
on you the little information that
exists on SCP 4205 was recorded by Wayde
dallet a former Junior researcher at the
foundation he wrote the initial report
on SCP 4205 on a computer terminal 4
though his work was highly valuable and
provided many previously unknown
insights about the nature of the SCP
sadly his knowledge could not save him
the official entry on SCP 4205 was his
final act before his death on December
11th
1992 before we get deeper into that
entry and Wade's final day on Earth it's
important to understand what SCP 4205 is
or at least understand the little we
know about what it is 4205 is a ker
class SCP meaning that it's incredibly
difficult or complicated to contain it
also shows extreme hostility toward all
life it is described as an amberol
colored pair of humanlike eyes with the
ability to appear spontaneously in
Windows mirrors or any other glass or
glass-like surface one of the reasons so
little is known about these eyes is that
anyone who sees them dies within seconds
much like the mythical basilisk The Gaze
of SCP 4205 is deadly and inescapable
the eyes only seem to appear to people
who are alone in a room and never in
places where there's more than one
person but aside from that there is no
way to predict where the eyes will
appear since it is unknown if the eyes
are part of a corporeal body or even
present on this plane of reality there
is no way to contain them or stop them
from killing this brings us to that
fateful day December 11th 1992 the day
that the SCP Foundation would finally be
given some tangible information on the
mysterious Amber eyes at the cost of one
of their researchers lives way dallot a
young man fresh out of his university
studies was brought on board as a junior
researcher by Dr Mark fory a senior
researcher Dr fory recruited Wade after
giving a guest lecture at his university
and being impressed by Wade's Keen
observational skills thirst for
knowledge of The Unexplained and
determination to understand that which
seemed to defy explanation after weade
graduated he was recruited by Dr foresy
and given the position of Junior
researcher at the SCP Foundation where
he assisted Dr fory now a site
supervisor in his research after several
months of working under Dr foresight
with minimal responsibilities Wade was
finally given the opportunity to write
his first SCP report on SCP
4205 following some initial documented
appearances of 4205 Dr forsight approved
further research into the anomaly with
Wade appointed as the lead researcher on
the subject according to Wade's entry he
was responsible for the discovery of SCP
4205 when he spotted the anomaly in a
window the later reviews of security
footage determined that he was not the
first person to observe the eyes he did
claim to be the first to observe them
and live to tell the Tale in his writing
on the subject Wade is puzzled by the
fact that he survived his encounter with
SCP
4205 and wonders what could have set him
apart from the others that fell victim
to its gaze he found himself frustrated
as he documented SCP
4205 his rough drafts of reports
dissolving into angry rants about his
own incompetence Wayne had difficulty
adjusting to his new responsibilities
especially with the added element of his
assigned subject's mysterious and
volatile nature in between his reports
on SCP 4205 its previous appearances and
its effects on its victims he wrote
letters to his father desperate for
reassurance that he was not messing
everything up letters that would sadly
go unsent in this coverage of SCP 4205
Wade made note of a troubling
reoccurring element in each victim's
death when medical professionals
attempted to revive the victims it was
always noted that their brain activity
stopped much more quickly than in cases
of death by natural causes when examined
all aspects of the body aside from the
brain were completely unharmed the brain
however showed massive nerve damage in
the amydala hippocampus medial temporal
lobe and occipital low the appearance of
this brain trauma had been compared to
the effects of electrical shock or a
severe head injury in addition to wade
six other people on record encountered
SCP
4205 every encounter ended the same way
with sudden brain death and severe nerve
damage immediately after viewing the
eyes in a reflective surface the first
encounter occurred on January 5th 1990
when Deputy Lea Zenna viewed the eyes in
a reflective glass oneway window
security tape reveals that the eyes
appeared in the Window 8 minutes before
the deputy leoon spotted them as soon as
he did he fell from his chair and
immediately died though the specifics
varied from case to case the end result
of every encounter was the same with
none UNS surviving long enough to relate
what they had experienced every
encounter except Wades as he continued
his documentation of SCP
4205 Wade's mental state quickly began
to deteriorate the process of his mind
coming apart and his thoughts giving way
to confusion fear and anger at his own
Survival is documented in his reports on
the SCP he agonized over the questions
of why he was able to survive gazing
into the eyes of SCP 4205 when so many
others had not the question consumed him
until he was unable to eat sleep or do
anything but obsess over the SCP he was
tasked with researching as he became
more agitated he began to write about
the eyes appearing to him again on one
occurrence he attempted to touch them
and described the sensation like
touching a balloon to your arm after it
had been charged with static electricity
he continued to report seeing the eyes
the worse was when trying to sleep
during which he was overtaken by viol
vent sleep paralysis and plagued with
visions of the Amber eyes the only
comfort Wade seemed to find was in
memories of his loved ones he wrote
about his mother and his father even as
their memories grew foggier to him he
also mentioned a man by the name of
Theodore Quail who he claimed was a
researcher at the foundation later
factchecking determined that this was
not the case and that Quail must have
been someone from Wade's past he wrote
about quail wistfully mournfully with
words of love and loss tormented by the
sense that he was losing his grip on
reality and everything he once held dear
as Wade descended deeper into a hell
inside his own mind he continued to mle
over the questions of SCP
4205 was there more to it than what was
visible did it have a body why had he
survived the encounter with it and what
did it want from him he decided that
those who had perished immediately were
the lucky ones they had escaped the
torture that had overtaken his life the
eyes were everywhere now watching him
even as he attacked tempted to unlock
their secrets on a foundation computer
he spoke to the eyes at one point but
refused to write down what they said to
him his last entry his last thought was
a plea for Theodore quail's Embrace
there is no more written about the
research or about the eyes only a simple
desperate need for a comfort that is
long lost now is the part of our story
where Terror meets tragedy contrary to
what Wade thought and what was recorded
in his final computer entries he did not
survive his brief brush with SCP
4205 the truth is that he spotted the
Amber eyes and the glass above his
terminal monitor while recording the
entry and died seconds later though his
death was Swift it felt agonizingly slow
as revealed by his descent into panic
and paranoia recorded in his writings
the entry is recorded as a result of the
connection weighed in the computer his
physical contact with it at the moment
of exposure to SCP 4205 anomalous
effects allow allowing the terminal to
Archive his final thoughts before he
succumbed to the deadly nature of the
eyes the entries were never physically
typed but rather jump from his dying
mind into the main frame his entries The
Echoes of a Dying mind offer a glimpse
into the way that SCP 4205 kills its
victims in the seconds leading up to
death the Amber eyes fast forward a
person's mind feeding on the electrical
impulses that it gives off as it speeds
through what seems to be days of fear
and of a loosening grip on reality the
death may be swift but the suffering is
long Wade left the foundation with a
digital fingerprint an echo of the
person he was at his core in addition to
his experiences with SCP 4205 itself
Wade spent his final moments terrified
for his life dreaming of a father that
he missed and a long lost love from his
college days his sacrifice must not be
forgotten because no one ever survived
IES an encounter with SCP
4205 his documented final moments are
the only firsthand account in existence
Junior researcher way doetz gave us a
gift in death he allowed the SCP
Foundation a glimpse into the true
horror of the Amber eyes and a reminder
of what they are capable of stealing
from us so be careful of Windows mirrors
screens and all reflective surfaces when
you look into them you never know know
what you might see looking back it's the
late '90s and an Air Canada flight
experiences severe malfunctions while
traveling from London to Vancouver the
pilots are unable to do anything and the
plane crashes into the woods of Northern
Alberta the crash was devastating only
10 of the nearly 300 people on board are
alive and even though they survived the
initial disaster their battle for life
has only just begun it's late autumn in
Northern Canada and there's no telling
when help will arrive
if at all if the survivors want to make
it through the night they need to find
shelter and fast as they trudge through
the freezing Woods the group finds a
path that looks like it might lead them
to civilization after all if there was a
path in the woods that meant they were
probably in a national park and if they
were in a national park there had to be
a ranger station around somewhere where
they could warm up and call for help
they didn't have many other options so
they followed the path which opened up
to a clearing but instead of finding a
ranger station or Campground they found
something none of them could have
expected it was a pond but there was
something off about it as they got
closer they saw that this strange Pond
wasn't filled with water but blood the
survivors were horrified that couldn't
really be blood could it it must have
been a weird allergy or chemical
reaction but one member of the group a
man named Thomas Dean who had been on
his way back to his hometown of Prince
George British Columbia thought there
was something strangely familiar about
this this he remembered being a boy and
going to visit family in Alberta and
hearing an urban legend from the older
local kids according to the stories
somewhere out in the wilderness in the
northern part of the province there was
a pond full of human blood and what made
it even worse was that some said the
pond was a gateway to Hell the SCP
Foundation was also aware of this Legend
and had been trying to pinpoint the
exact source of it for decades prior to
the Air Canada crash they would finally
receive definite confirmation of the
blood Pond when Foundation Personnel
intercepted a radio transmission from a
ranger station located within the Wood
Buffalo national park it was the
survivors of the crash who had managed
to make it through the night and they
were about to be escorted out of the
park by Rangers the foundation mobilized
quickly to cordon off the pond as at the
time they were unsure of what
potentially harmful properties the pond
might have had they set up watch station
Epsilon 38 and put staff on guard to
deter travelers from the area the pond
was was given the designation of SCP 354
and classed as uclid Foundation
scientists made a number of interesting
discoveries about sccp 354 when they
collected samples for testing first the
pond was not in fact full of blood
merely an inorganic liquid that closely
resembles blood in color and consistency
second and even Stranger Than The Red
liquid is that the pond doesn't seem to
have any definite Banks or a bottom
instead the liquid in the pond increases
in density as the radius away from the
center increases the liquid congeals at
the edges becoming more solid and
blending into the surrounding soil it
also becomes thicker as one descends
deeper into the pool and the bottom of
the pond has not yet been reached if it
even exists initially the foundation
found no signs of life within the blood
Pond but that would all change at 2:03
p.m. on the day following the opening of
Watch Station Epsilon 38 when the
science team noticed an unusual level of
activity on the Pond's surface security
footage feed feed showed a shape rising
out of the pond followed by a deafening
shriek after that the feed was cut and
Foundation lost all communication with
watch station Epsilon 38 fearing the
worst a mobile task force was dispatched
to the location when they got there all
Personnel at the watch station had been
killed by what could only be described
as a gigantic bat the task force was
able to neutralize the entity and as
soon as they could the foundation moved
in to increase security around the SCP
creating area 354 and installing a
permanent security detail after this
point the pond started to regularly spit
out a variety of monstrous entities
almost as if it was reacting to the SCP
foundation's increased security measures
after SCP 3541 the giant bat came SCP
3542 3542 was an Aida likee monster the
size of a bear that was virtually
bulletproof but unable to escape area
354 the foundation neutralized this
anomaly with Napal scp3 3 54-3 was a
floating black sphere capable of firing
deadly beams of concentrated energy the
area's head scientist was able to hit it
with a sledgehammer causing the sphere
to malfunction and self-destruct before
it was able to escape the area the
foundation wasn't as lucky with SCP
3544 this creature was a reptilian
humanoid that stood roughly 15 ft tall
and was unable to be put down with
gunfire this was the first Creature from
the pond to successfully Escape
containment and was only able to be
neutralized when the foundation sent in
Mobile task force Omega 7 also known as
Pandora's Box the data on Pond
incursions is partially corrupted so a
complete list of creatures is not
available but some of the other monsters
that came out of the blood Pond include
a killer robot a set of gigantic
tentacles that drag several d-class
Personnel into the pond a pair of
panther-like creatures one made of ice
and the other of magma that ignored
Foundation staff and instead fought each
other and one seemingly normal human man
who was executed as soon as he emerged
from the pond tests on his body revealed
that he was in fact totally normal and
would have posed no threat these
anomalies came out of the pond at fairly
regular intervals for several months
before the pond went silent for an
unprecedented 22 months the head
scientist at the time noted I suspect
this means one of two things either the
red pool has died or powered down or
whatever the correct term for it is or
is charging up for something big to come
through ofi believes the former is the
most likely explanation and has recalled
30% of our total personnel and cut 25%
of our funding while I can only hope
that they are correct if the latter
situation is true we're soon to face
some terrible monstrosity and we won't
have anywhere near the force necessary
to deal with it I worry for all of our
safety his words would prove eily
prophetic following the events of
exploratory Mission 354 Alpha the
foundation's research and development
team built a specialized craft to
explore the pond because of the strange
properties of the Pond's density the
craft was essentially made to be both a
submarine for parts of the pond where
the contents were liquid and a drill for
when the liquid congealed into a
semi-solid towards the bottom the
exploration team consisted of agent
Swanson agent turquoise agent 86 Dr J
MacArthur Chris Simmons Leroy Tucker and
a pilot named Martin with the team
assembled the ship was sent down into
the pond nothing eventful happened for
the first 2 days of the mission but at
4:30 a.m. on on the third day gravity
suddenly reversed for the crew of the
ship this seemed to indicate that they
were approaching the halfway point
though what would be on the other side
nobody could say on the fourth day the
ship surfaced proving definitely that
the pond was in fact some sort of portal
the crew looked out of the port holes to
see the darkness of night above them
while sensors outside the ship detected
nothing harmful in the atmosphere around
them the crew were wary of exiting the
craft the other side of the pond was
nothing like the world the crew knew for
one thing the night lasted for 28 hours
before Dawn came and when the Sun
finally Rose it was much larger and
redder than the Earth's sun under the
light of the strange red star the crew
could see that the pond on this side was
massive compared to what they've come
into more like a large lake surrounding
the lake was sand and rocks that were
covered in a kind of moss that
disappeared under sunlight and regrew
during the night the team left the ship
and started to explore during their time
in This Strange World they found found
that the day lasted just a few hours
shorter than the night meaning that
whatever Planet they were on had a
roughly 43h hour long rotation as
opposed to our own planets 24 the team
found a number of anomalous elements on
their expedition including razor sharp
grass that can puncture skin and streams
of liquid carbon dioxide they heard some
loud Roars in the distance once or twice
but other than that the planet was
eerily silent with seemingly no animal
life and not even wind when it rained
the soil remained dry and based on that
the scientist theorized the plants in
this world were more efficient at
absorbing moisture on the 25th day the
team ran into a huge metal wall that
appeared to be artificially constructed
luckily Leroy Tucker a quick-thinking
researcher was able to rig a blowtorch
from camping supplies and melt a hole
through the metal on the other side
there was finally wind and odd black
grass that's the extent of what is known
about the other side of the wall because
the Expedition logs are heavily
corrupted after that point but we know
that what whatever was in there wasn't
good because the team never returned
strangely there's no record of any names
mentioned in the ship's log almost as if
being killed on the other side
completely erased them from history no
other Expeditions into the pond were
launched after that on an undisclosed
day a year following the discovery of
the blood Pond and construction of area
354 the site was completely evacuated
and power was cut to the area mobile
task force data 12 was dispatched to
investigate the cause of the evacuation
but before contact could be established
the area's on-site nuclear warhead was
detonated completely destroying the site
MTF Theta 12 was then attacked by a
convoy made up of d-class and other
low-ranking staff who had evacuated area
354 it was apparent that there had been
some kind of muty within the site and
that a dissolution of the chain of
command had led to its evacuation and
destruction the Convoy totally
annihilated MTF data 12 and no further
contact with the former Personnel of
area 354 has been made since
following the site's detonation a new
site was constructed called simply the
red pool containment site unlike the
previous facility which focused on
research and neutralization the new site
is entirely concerned with containment
the shift and directive came as a
response to the Pond's apparent reactive
nature each creature that emerged from
the pond seemed to be in retaliation to
the foundation's actions and it was
theorized by some that the Mutiny at
area 354 was triggered by some kind of
psychic attack from the pond itself in
an interview in the SCP file on 354
reveals that there was one more
disastrous attempt to control and
understand the blood Pond according to
an interview with a foundation agent the
head doctor proposed a scheme to drain
the blood Pond using a system of pumps
and hoses all non-essential Personnel
were evacuated in case of emergency
leaving only the pump technicians
d-class personnel and a few agents for
security however as soon as the pump was
scheduled to be turned on everyone at
the side experienced a mass dissociated
episode the agent described the feeling
they all experienced as like being in a
dream and suddenly realizing that you're
asleep he said everything stopped being
real it was like we had to Escape right
now when asked what happened when the
pump was turned on he simply explained
that it wouldn't let them this interview
confirmed the theory that the pond is
not only capable of releasing monsters
out into our world but also that it's
capable of powerful but much more subtle
psychological attacks this suggests a
chilling possibility that the pond isn't
just blindly reacting to being attacked
but it's fully sentient and the actions
of the SCP Foundation have only serve to
annoy it and worst studies of the Pond's
banks have proved evidence that the area
of congealed liquid around the perimeter
of the pond has been steadily expanding
that's right the pond is getting bigger
the last thing the foundation agent
stationed at the site said before being
dragged out of the interview and sedated
was it gets bigger and stronger every
day and now we've made it Angry mobile
task force Edna 84 also known by the
code name and thus upon his Crucible is
on one of the strangest missions they've
ever been sent on they sit in a darkened
room beads of sweat trickling down their
brows the lights of computer monitors
shine upon their faces they're tackling
a monster that if it escapes will
literally devour all of creation it has
no fear it has no remorse and if it
isn't kept contained by Edna 84 it may
escape and wreck havoc across the world
oh and did we mention it's trapped in a
Minecraft server you heard us right SCP
4335 is a Cognito hazardous
extradimensional being of pure Terror
trapped inside a procedurally generated
world in the immensely popular game
Minecraft you hear about a lot of
horrifying monsters being described as
lovecraftian but only this monster is
minecraftian there's a lot that needs
explaining here and we intend to get to
all of it but let's start with how the
foundation keeps This truly exceptional
Beast contained the foundation first
discovered SCP 4335 back in 2010 shortly
after the Alpha version of Minecraft was
released because of the online nature of
the game it's proven to be impossible to
contain 4335 externally seeing as it
isn't confined to any one physical
location shutting off the server 4335 5
is found in is not an effective
containment method either as this just
causes the entity to Simply hop to a
different server the foundation's
greatest fear is that 4335 will one day
make the leap out of Minecraft and cause
chaos in our world that's why it's
imperative to draft containment
procedures for SCP 4335 within the game
this led to the creation of a
containment site unlike any other site
M1 the first official Foundation site
made in entirely out of Minecraft blocks
everyone who was originally involved in
the server has been removed and
amnestied since then El lead SCP
Foundation containment Specialists and
Gamers have been constructing the
perfect prison for SCP
4335 site M1 is a large Stone complex
built into the side of a mountain it has
a number of key features including a
supply area filled with materials vital
for 4335 continued containment chests
filled with books that that contain SCP
4335 containment procedures a few animal
farms for the purpose of breeding and
killing livestock for their meat the
entrance to a mine several chests
containing books specifically designed
for civilians to learn about
4335 if they ever breach containment and
enter the server and of course the
actual containment chamber for SCP 4335
itself which is a little more
complicated 4335 is containment chamber
is built out of several layers all made
from iron blocks the outermost cube is
75x 75x 75 blocks the inner cube is 55x
55x 55 blocks and the innermost cube is
25x 25x 25 blocks creating several
levels of Defense finally one layer
within all these others which contains
the anomaly proper is made from obsidian
blocks SCP 4335 is bound into the center
of the the containment chamber with a
complex mechanism the uttermost cube is
completely filled with water and several
dispensers capable of rapidly dispensing
large amounts of items in a short amount
of time line the cube the cube also
contains several mob Farms which are
devices that constantly spawn enemies
into the chamber that drop loot when
they die the chamber is essentially
designed to funnel a constant flow of
items inwards to SCP
4335 there are even contingency measures
for if SCP 4335 manages to breach
containment if Escape is attempted
blocks of TNT detonate above the ceiling
causing lava to pour into the chamber at
that point MTF Edna 84 are dispatched
into the server to lure 4335 back into
its containment chamber to do this they
fire a mix of fire resistant potions and
ender pearls which have teleportation
capabilities interestingly there's one
more basic method of luring SCP 4335
back into the obsidian Que taunting and
insulting one of SCP 4335 is many
anomalous abilities is being able to
hear people through the screen and being
a proud creature it often responds to
insults by charging in to directly
Engage The insulter if SCP 4335 still
manages to breach the containment that
has been set up for it then they even
expect that it will likely soon hop into
another's server at that point the goal
will shift to finding the monster and
recontain it with containment procedures
this complex and extensive it shouldn't
come as a surprise that SCP 4335 rests
firmly in the ker class what exactly is
this anomalous entity why does its
containment hinge on constantly
providing it with items and how did it
end up in Mojang's popular building and
survival game in the first place SCP
4335 in terms of physical dimensions
appears almost identical to the player
character with an all black skin it also
appears to be constantly shrouded in a
cloud of smoke particles and has long
black tendrils protruding from its back
in some respects 4335 has been compared
to two popular Creepy Pasta figures
Herobrine and the Slenderman but 4335 is
far stranger its physical body behaves
similarly to most assets native to the
game with a few peculiar anomalous
abilities we'll discuss soon handling a
SCP 433 5 is an extremely delicate
process if command blocks creative mode
or server commands are ever enabled in a
server with SCP
4335 the server will instantly shut down
and SCP 4335 will move to a different
server SCP 4335 also uses its tendrils
to destroy surrounding blocks before
consuming them with each successful
consumption SCP 4335 grows and when it
reaches sufficient size it hops to a
different server as you can see keeping
a SCP 4335 contained is an uphill battle
but luckily there are two factors on the
foundation side here the first is that
SCP 4335 is immobilized while consuming
items and blocks limiting its ability to
actively Escape Foundation forces the
second factor is that SCP 4335 needs a
rest period between consuming blocks in
order to grow meaning if its consumption
is constant and continous
it isn't able to grow these two factors
have informed the entirety of the
foundation's containment procedures
around SCP
4335 it's locked into its chamber and
fed items and blocks constantly
effectively rooting it in place when SCP
4335 begins to grow the foundation also
found that the application of Ender
Pearls helps reduce it back to its
normal size however SCP 4335 does have a
method of striking back at against its
captors 4335 is a virgin class
multi-sensory Cognito Hazard anyone
viewing it without proper training and
protection may experience distressing
hallucinations SCP 4335 is also capable
of telepathic speech with people playing
on its server and as we alluded to
earlier it can also hear any noises you
make while playing weird is a term
thrown around a lot when it comes to
scps considering it's pretty much a
requirement for for the foundation to
take interest in you but an all
devouring Minecraft demon that can hear
you talking through your screen is
strange even by Foundation standards MTF
Edna 84 first discovered SCP 4335 in the
single player server of Minecraft user
leaking heart three team members Jason
yelen Richard Duchamp and sheilia
Freemason covertly entered the game to
investigate and potentially apprehend
the creature when leaking Hart first
discovered their presence on what he
thought was a priv private server he
quickly left a little creeped out by the
sudden intrusion thankfully the trio was
still able to locate SCP
4335 they discovered the creature hiding
inside a giant crater as though it had
impacted the Earth at considerable speed
Richard Duchamp who was the leader of
the team at the time made the mistake of
looking directly at the entity in that
moment he experienced the full force of
SCP 4335 Cognito hazardous effects he
hallucinated ated believing that his
keyboard was melting before his eyes in
the aftermath of this incident Duchamp
was taken off the case and Jason yelson
was promoted to head of the project
things were still going to get stranger
yelson was able to open a dialogue with
the creature after containing it in a
chamber filled with lava it asked him
whether it had landed in the right
location meaning our world and yelson
informed him that had somehow fallen
into the world of Minecraft instead the
creature was at first confused and then
angry and resentful about its situation
it vowed to find its way into our world
somehow and obtain more sustenance a few
months after this The Entity managed to
breach containment and hop into another
server yelson and two others once again
managed to track it down and recontain
it but this time two civilians also
inhabiting the server were exposed to
the anomalous effects of SCP
4335 they weren't hurt but they did
appear strange and incoherent After
experiencing 43 35's Cognito hazards the
foundation tracked them down in the
aftermath and gave them amnestic
treatment 4335 was contained shortly
thereafter once again yelson came face
to face with his new foe 8 months after
being captured 4335 granted yelson
another interview from containment 4335
admitted that it almost respected yelson
and the rest of the foundation for
figuring out how to capture and contain
it so quickly in exchange it would give
the foundation something extremely
valuable information first it asked one
question of yelson how does he Define
creation yelson replied uh something
that is built and brought into this
universe by a Sapient being using other
things from this universe 4335 agreed it
went on to explain that it came from a
universe devoid of creation a dark and
unknowable Place filled with nothing but
violent random chaos its Dimension
existed directly above ours and it often
looked down at us through a dimensional
window fascinated by all the creation
below it plotted and dreamed to one day
infiltrate our reality and yelson
finally had the opportunity to ask the
magic question why though he wasn't
quite ready for the brutal honesty of
SCP
4335 is reply why I do not like to lie
so I will tell you now I wish to suck it
dry of the toys of whatever Force
controls your Universe destroy the light
destroy the Earth and Destroy Humanity
it reminded me of me a blubbering mass
of intelligence and order it sickens me
in ways I cannot
comprehend I hope you understand
SCP 4335 was a connoisseur of creation
and had sought to devour all of it in
this moment yelson realized what an
incredibly dangerous entity he was
dealing with the only mystery was why
this creature had somehow landed in
Minecraft instead of our world which
appeared to be the only thing that saved
us but yelson didn't have time to think
4335 was about to Stage another daring
escape attempt one of its tendrils
reached reached out and attacked yon's
player character in that moment the real
life yelson began to hallucinate and
panic suddenly back in the game a series
of abnormally tall slender black figures
appeared and began deconstructing the
containment chamber around SCP
4335 it had somehow summoned new minions
into the game to assist in this
Containment Breach Jason yelson entered
Cognito Hazard quarantine following this
incident and was removed from the
project and he wasn't the the only one
affected by this incident following the
first appearance of these long dark
figures players across the globe began
to experience them appearing in their
own games the foundation managed to find
a solution they contacted Mojang and had
the creatures patched into the game
during the next update as a new
nonanomalous entity which seemed to stop
4335 from being able to use them as its
own tools they're now known as the
Enderman and are beloved among fans for
being one of the creepier enemies to
this day containment efforts continue
for SCP
4335 but there's only one question left
why did The Entity fall into Minecraft
rather than our world the file posits
the most likely answer because 4335
defines creation as elements made by
Sapient beings in Minecraft the most
popular game in the world at the height
of 4335 is power everything that exists
is the product of code made by humans
creation is truly abundant there as for
our world in SCP 4335 extra-dimensional
eyes there is no creation no intelligent
design no soothing piano soundtrack just
frightening chaotic Randomness which is
too unlike its own Dimension so even if
SCP 4335 ever did arrive in our reality
it would likely be disappointed by how
little there is to eat ask yourself a
simple question is the world around you
real it seems like the answer should be
pretty obvious of course the world as
you know it is real how else would you
be able to interact with it perhaps a
better question would be this how much
do you trust that the world you know is
real how much do you believe that
reality as you experience it is constant
and cannot be changed by external
forces now imagine if you can an entity
to which the very fabric of reality is
like clay able to be shaped and molded
at will then imagine that this entity
this malicious twisted and unknowable
horror has taken a special interest in
you if you can picture such a scenario
then you may as well be standing in the
shoes of James tallaran a foundation
researcher assigned to SCP
3999 tallaran could only have imagine
what the foundation kept contained in an
airtight cell all the way at the bottom
of a kilometer long shaft and never
expected that this was where his
lifeless body would be found despite
having the entity contained the
foundation's only knowledge of SCP 3999
came from a text document discovered on
taran's phone after his demise even
their own records indicated that no such
creature ever existed why what could
possibly shape reality in such a way
that it could hide its own existence
from the
foundation and where was it now the
document on tolerance phone yielded some
evidence seeming to be a long rambling
and Confused account of some sort of
battle between a reality shaping entity
and the ill- fated researchers sent to
examine it unlike many of the
foundation's documents the entry for SCP
3999 is riddled with contradictions and
strikethroughs a confusing mess of
information that makes piecing together
the mysteries of talin's Fate all the
more difficult beneath the strange
formatting and uncertainty surrounding
SCP $ 39.99 lies the tale of one man's
torture for the amusement of an
impossibly powerful and eternally
sadistic creature based on the
information available it appears that
SCP 3999 was fixated on tallaran upon
his arrival to the entity's cell the
researcher had no idea how long he would
spend in the company of SCP 3999 or that
he would never emerge alive many scps
contained by the foundation require
their own specially made prison in order
to hold them and maintain the safety of
foundation staff as well as the outside
world but imagine if an SCP could turn
the tables bending the world around a
single member of the foundation using
all of reality as their own personalized
torture chamber the list of Horrors
endured by tallaran is both exhaustive
and incomplete given the length of time
he spent with the creature shortly after
James Taran was assigned to site 118
where SCP 3999 was contained The Entity
was somehow able to breach containment
and began to twist the world around it
in the name of a singular cruel
objective the torture of James
tallaran the creature while having no
physical description possessed the
capability to cause either a CK class
reality restructuring event or a ZK
Class end of reality event SCP 3999 was
somehow able to both destroy reality
itself while simultaneously rebuilding
it around its prisoner researcher Taran
Every Creature person and mination that
SCP 3999 created was done so with the
express intention of making tarant
suffer horribly over the course of
millions of years according to the
researchers own writings the exact
details of how SCP 3999 tortur Taran are
littered throughout the document he was
found with but it is apparent that the
entity was able to use its reality
altering abilities to continually revive
the man after killing him as a way to
prolong his pain SCP 3999 seemed to be
able to use its powers however it
pleased but focused all its attention
and actions on causing misery for one
man it simply enjoyed inflicting
suffering one of the examples of the
atrocities James Talan suffered at the
mercy of a cold remorseless creature was
witnessing the deaths of others although
they were constructed and controlled by
SCP 3999 Taran saw Train Foundation
security Personnel drag three people
into the cell he recognized them
instantly as his own family Talan was
made to watch as his mother father and
sister were executed with a single
gunshot to the head by members of the
same organization that he was a part of
all of taran's professional colleagues
were also killed in front of him
followed by anyone and everyone that had
come into contact with James tallaran
including the 05 Council he was made to
watch as they were systematically
murdered one by one all for the
enjoyment of SCP
3999 at some point during the creatures
torture of Taran there appears to have
been some attempt to contain SCP 3999
within another SCP SCP
2432 a room within a hotel now owned by
the foundation that appears to compel
its guests to write exaggerated positive
reviews after staying there when
introduced to SCP
2432 SCP 39 99's ability to alter
reality seemed to have the effect of
creating a dimensional anomaly within
the hotel a crawl space opened up in SCP
2432 leading to an almost identical room
the front door of this new room
designated SCP
24321 led to an alternate Dimension that
resembled the hotel housing SCP
2432 the rooms of this new version of
the SCP 2432 Hotel were a seemingly
infinite endless loop of rooms this
Dimension also played host to a number
of strange creatures as uncovered by
Foundation research teams that ventured
there most notably a creature resembling
a male Homo Sapien calling itself
researcher tallaran this being was
dressed in clothing similar to
Foundation researchers and appeared
nervous and confused when approached by
personnel only to be executed when asked
to be told the location of SCP
3999 later during SCP 39 99's 3 milliony
year torture session James tallaran was
interviewed with another doctor working
for the
foundation the interviewing doctor had
no recollection of taran's assignment to
SCP
3999 and both James's involvement with
the foundation and the Very existence of
SCP 3999 were expunged from the
foundation's database as Taran
desperately tried to rationalize what
was happening to him he told the
interviewer I have trouble focusing on
things now I just just feel a lot of
unease it's like reality has started to
feel less real if that makes sense
shortly after he attempted to ask the
doctor for his name and for him to
identify which of the foundation sites
they were at in response the doctor
emitted a strange noise from his mouth
confusing Taran that's not a name you
just made a noise with your mouth the
researcher replied why am I thinking of
redactions how can a word be redacted
like that in a normal conversation
following this the floor beneath James
talin's feet disappeared and he was
swallowed by Darkness as SCP 3999
continued bending reality to make him
suffer What followed were multiple
failed attempts from Taran to either
Escape From The Entity or nullify its
abilities to warp reality SCP 3999 had
at a later Point trapped Taran in a
stage playay version of itself as James
frantically tried to escape out of a
nearby door where he hoped to find
reality he was met with a solid wall I'm
trapped in whatever this place is with
this thing and there's no outside
reality anymore he realized researcher
Taran tried to understand the entity but
SCP 3999 defied description it was
simply chaos in his desperation Torin
was able to dig a tiny hole in the floor
through which he could see a light
filled with thoughts of his beloved
family his colleagues and the rest of
the world that had once existed he
opened the hole wider it is unclear what
happened after this but it it is
apparent that James tallaran was still
unable to escape SCP
3999 however as the situations he found
himself and grew increasingly strange
James Taran was able to take greater
control of his predicament this is
evidenced in the foundation's document
regarding SCP
3999 researcher tallaran cannot be
contained by this researcher tallaran
will fight his way back researcher Taran
will recontain SCP
this torture had gone on long enough and
researcher James Taran was determined to
be free of the creature that had taken
such sick pleasure in his pain Tarin at
one point was able to subdue SCP
3999 although it is initially unclear
how he accomplished this there were
several attempts made to contain the
entity using a recursive joke a melon
the graves of American Crime novelist
Robert B Parker or an 05 council member
in a roach motel It is believed that
every single one of these attempts
failed attempting to beat the creature
at its own game Taran tried to turn SCP
3999 reality altering Powers against it
by imagining The Entity as something
easier to subdue these included several
moldy blankets a murderous penguin and a
pillow eventually Taran was able to
contain SCP 3999 with the aid of 48
trained containment Personnel all of
whom were also researcher Taran during
this time a conversation between the two
were partially recorded although any
dialogue from SCP 3999 suffered from
data corruption claiming to finally be
in charge and in control of the
situation tallaran interrogated SCP 3999
berading the creature for keeping him
prisoner you can't frighten me anymore
for the first million years of
nonsensical containment procedures and
tortures and dream logic it was the
worst pain I had ever felt but I
survived for the second million years it
was still the hardest thing I had ever
done but I survived by the third million
years I was growing numb the researcher
tried to ascertain the exact nature and
origin of SCP
3999 but to no avail vowing to fight The
Entity Torin told it here's the thing
about horror and weirdness the more you
reveal of it the less effect it has I am
sick of your horror I am sick of you
afterwards he was melted into goo for
for 5 years it appears that shortly
after this researcher teleran managed to
understand how to destroy SCP
3999 while the entity was Immortal and
virtually Unstoppable he realized its
weakness that it had to bond to another
being in order to survive upon
discovering this tallaran took his own
life causing all that SCP 3999 had done
to disappear after Foundation researcher
James Taran committed suicide reality
reverted to its original state before
SCP 3999 had heavily altered it his
death freeing reality from the evil
entity once and for all the foundation
remains unaware of what SCP 3999 was or
indeed is and one can only guess as to
why the entity subjugated tyin to such
Terror and horror what made this
powerful reality Bender holds such a
perverse fixation on one man some have
likened the creature to a horror writer
continually subjugating a character to
all manner of nightmares before deciding
to redraft and try something new
whatever it was sccp 3999 carries with
it a warning that reality isn't always
as it seems Joseph and Frank were two
lifelong squatchers no that isn't an
insult that's a self-given title for
bigfoot enthusiasts who are willing to
head out into the woods and search for
the legendary Sasquatch firsthand While
most squatchers will go their whole
lives without ever encountering one
Joseph and Frank were about to get lucky
they just didn't know what kind of luck
during a journey through the forest of
the Pacific Northwest Frank spotted
something moving in the distance a huge
ap-like creature with grayish fur and
human-like movements Frank thought he
was finally laying eyes on the mighty
Bigfoot after Decades of searching what
he didn't know was that he just made a
deadly mistake he had looked directly at
SCP 1000 and there would be terrible
consequences Frank was excited he just
achieved the life goal of any squatcher
he tapped Joseph on the shoulder and
directed him to look in the direction of
the creature Joseph followed Frank's
Direction and stared into the distance
when his eyes finally came into focus on
the aplike Beast he froze his brain just
short circuited one second he was about
to encounter the Holy Grail of his Hobby
and the next he was literally brain dead
Joseph collapsed in the distance the
aplike creature disappeared back into
the woods not that Frank even noticed he
was too busy trying to wake Joseph but
it was no use Joseph was gone and Frank
had no idea why the headlines read
Bigfoot killed my friend most people
either ignored it or laughed it off just
a couple of cranks goofing off in a
forest and one of them had dropped dead
who cares well one organization cared
the SCP Foundation mobile task force
Zeta 1000 the foundation specialized SCP
1000 detail were alerted to the reports
they sprang into action tracking down
and detaining Frank for questioning they
process a million Looney Bigfoot lovers
every year and usually find nothing but
the death of Frank's friend made it all
too clear they hadn't encountered a
Bigfoot but a real genuine example of
SCP
1000 scp1000 rarely ranks among the
scariest or most dangerous scps but
underestimating the creature is a
terrible mistake because just looking at
it gives you a 2% chance of dropping
dead on the spot Frank despite losing
his friend was one of the lucky ones the
foundation debriefed him before
administering amnestics and making sure
that he'd never Venture back into those
mysterious forests in the Pacific
Northwest region director Jones the site
director charged with the management of
SCP 1000 populations was given the
information on this latest case of an
SCP 1000 related fatality it was a story
he heard many times before for director
Jones they all seemed to bleed into one
another so what exactly is SCP 1000 and
how did it leave poor Joseph dead in the
woods scp1000 is a whole species of
large homed aplike creatures they're
largely nocturnal but sightings of the
creature during the day aren't unheard
of they're omnivorous mostly seeming to
consume plants and insects and their fur
is usually gray brown black red or
occasionally white the creatures have
large eyes capable of impressive Vision
nestled underneath a pronounced
Neanderthal likee brow another defining
feature is the ridge of bone on the
forehead much like that of a gorilla
that is present in both sexes according
to Foundation studies the creatures
exhibit a level of Intelligence on par
with that of the common chimpanzee but
nowhere near that of us humans what they
lack in intelligence though they make up
for in size the adults can be as large
as 10 ft tall and weigh up to 600 lb
despite their great size and impressive
strength the creatures are neither
aggressive nor territorial in fact they
seem to instinctively avoid humans
mostly residing deep in the forest of
the American Pacific Northwest and in
the Himalayan Alps there have been
sightings of SCP 1000 on every continent
though the foundation has taken pains to
exterminate all SCP 1000 populations
situated near human population centers
to prevent a potential disaster
considering the 2% chance of
instantaneous death upon visual contact
that brings us to our second question
what is it that makes these seemingly
harmless creatures so dangerous sadly
for both these unfortunate creatures and
US humans the danger is beyond the
control of SCP 1000
according to Foundation research SCP
1000 likely evolved alongside us Homo
sapiens until a tragedy occurred between
10 and 15,000 years ago a mysterious
Extinction event eliminated the vast
majority of their species leaving only 1
to 5% alive in the aftermath what
happened it's believed that around this
time scp1000 contracted what the
foundation refers to as an anomalous
pseudo disease Meet SCP 1000 F1 a
disease that is passed along at the
genetic level and is so durable that it
persists in the species to this day the
tiny fraction of the population that are
immune to its effects manag to survive
but the majority who aren't immune die
shortly after birth this is why the
overall population remains relatively
low to this day it's a disease that only
appears to affect hominids including
humans chimpanzees bonobos and
non-immune instances of
scp1000 any homonid that lays eyes on a
carrier of the disease has a 2% chance
of experiencing immediate brain death
while a 2% chance of instant death may
not seem all that threatening at least
when compared to some other nightmare
inducing scps the truly scary part is
that the percentage is cumulative in
other words the longer one observes a
carrier of SCP 1000 F1 the higher that
percentage Rises the greater your chance
of experiencing an Abrupt death
according to Foundation studies the
percentage Rises by around 1% every 20
minutes and the percentage also varies
between between specimens with some
exhibiting a terrifyingly high death
chance of 90% upon viewing this death
chance continues to occur in dead
specimens if they carry the anomalous
pseudovirus while alive though
thankfully the risk doesn't appear to
apply to small fur or tissue samples the
foundation's true concern actually goes
far beyond SCP 1000 themselves because
of the species close relation to Homo
sapiens there's a worry that SCP 1000 F1
could transmit to humans causing our own
species to meet a similar fate if humans
did indeed become carriers of SCP 10000
F1 it's extremely likely that Humanity
would undergo an unprecedented
Extinction event with billions across
the globe dropping dead as brain death
sets in on mass while full extermination
of the entire species has been deemed
unlikely this existential threat they
pose to humanity more than justifies the
occasional culling of SCP 1000
populations that was a lot to take in
right first the creature we thought was
Bigfoot was actually a new species of
SCP out in the wild and second these
creatures could end human life as we
know it if they made it into a
population Center but what you're about
to hear next a dark secret only
available to people with level three SCP
Foundation clearance is the most
shocking SCP 100000 fact of all are you
ready the true secret of SCP 100000 is
that what you've just heard is a lie
there is no anomalous pseudo disease and
scp1000 poses no path enic threat to
humanity whatsoever who would spread
such a thing the SCP Foundation of
course strictly speaking the foundation
has disseminated two direct lies about
the nature of SCP 1000 the first is that
of the disease which does not exist nor
has it ever existed the second lie is
about the creatures intelligence level
they're far smarter than the average
Chimp in fact they're every bit as
intelligent as human beings these were
all lies formulated by director Jones
and the foundation as was the very
existence of the Bigfoot myth the
foundation has been spreading
information that makes the very concept
of the Sasquatch out to be a joke for
decades all to discredit and further
push the very concept of SCP 1000 into
the Shadows but why the foundation is no
stranger to coming up with cover stories
but why would they put intentional lies
into their own files to anyone below a
level three clearance well that all
comes down to the horrifying truth
behind the origins of today's SCP 1000
population the creatures were first
brought to the attention of the
foundation by Outcast members of the
Serpent's hand an organization dedicated
to Defying the foundation's activities
these members known as The Children Of
The Sun told them the secret history of
SCP 1000 well at first Foundation
Personnel like director Jones didn't
want to believe what they were hearing
they soon came to terms with the
horrifying truth humans in scp1000 did
evolve alongside each other with humans
occupying the day and SCP 1000 the night
how however while humans were still
basic hunter gatherers scp1000 were
undergoing vast intellectual and
societal development they were able to
create tools weapons agriculture stable
settlements domesticated animals and
eventually even fully developed cities
it was like nothing the world had ever
seen and wouldn't see for thousands of
years to come their numbers swelled into
the tens of billions as they created
culture and Technology hitherto
unimagined including weapons of
devastating power meanwhile Humanity was
pushed to the brink of Destruction by
their competitor's rapid and seemingly
Unstoppable growth it looked as though
the human species had lost the
evolutionary arms race and would have to
bow out but according to the Children Of
The Sun a trickster Forest God smiled
upon humanity and gave them the power to
use SCP 1000's weapons and Technology
against them 70% of SCP 1000's
population were wiped out in a single
horrific day known to the children of
the Sun as the day of the flowers as
every flower supposedly bloomed that day
during the massacre Humanity destroyed
the entire civilization and with the
same technology they stole from these
unfortunate creatures the vengeful
humans drove the Apes mad their higher
consciousnesses were blocked out
reducing them back into the states of
mere animals once the massacre was done
and everything that was built had been
destroyed we the human race used the SCP
1000 weapons to wipe any memory of the
atrocity from our own minds the advanced
civilization of SCP 1000 had been wiped
from history humans returned to their
plotting path of evolution none the
wiser for thousands of years all the way
up until today this time remained a
mystery to us so again why did the
foundation lie to us what did they have
to gain by convincing us all that it was
dangerous to even look at these
creatures while as the frequency of
sightings and the attempts of
communication increased people like
director Jones became aware of a
frightening possibility what if the
pendulum was swinging back what if the
Apes were regaining their lost
intelligence and worse still harbored
feelings of Revenge for what we did to
their species thousands of years ago
even the mere possibility that they
could do to us what we once did to them
is a chance that the foundation simply
cannot take and thus limiting contact
between humans and SCP 1000 at all costs
is an absolute must however in spite of
the foundation's fears one intercepted
message from the ape suggests that their
paranoia may be misplaced this message
translated from an attempt at
communicating with Foundation Personnel
reads simply as follows we forgive you
given choice for now not forever let us
back in it's enough to make you wonder
what species the foundation should
really be keeping tabs on here after all
when it comes to meting out violence and
death Humanity has a track record to
rival the worst creatures in the
foundation containment cells and few
examples illustrate that better than the
tragic case of SCP 1000 Corpses littered
the facility around 20 in total their
Massacre had unfolded in a matter of
seconds despite their Advanced armor and
heavy Weaponry their killer wielding an
ancient sword he'd somehow pulled from
thin air looked upon them with disdain
weak unworthy opponents he breathed
heavily his torso was covered with
bullet wounds and many had punctured his
lungs it was enough to kill a normal Man
10 times over but not him he was The
Ultimate Warrior the perfect killing
machine he would need to seek out an
enemy more fitting for his legendary
combat skills he fled from the chamber
into a connecting hallway where a giant
metal door slam shut behind him at the
other end of a hall another door did the
same he laughed at the thought of
someone thinking he could be trapped so
easily and charg towards it but then
large valves began to open all around
him torrents of freezing sea water began
pouring in filling up the chamber and
submerging him before he could reach the
door the warrior fought for breath and
yelled it far longer than any mortal man
could especially considering the state
of his lungs but water always wins he
soon gave his last gasp and floated
lifeless in the hallway and soon after
his body turned to dust and disappeared
in the Briny water but he would be back
he'd always be back his brother was a
different story tall and handsome with a
strange Sumerian Rune tattooed on his
forehead he was practically a pacifist
and spent most of his days reading
conversing with the staff and wandering
the facility of his own accord upon
hearing of the latest incident at the
facility he gave a sigh he knew on some
level that all of this was his fault
it'd been centuries Millennia even but
was it too late to make things right 6
days later the two are standing face to
face this meeting had been a long time
time coming but it was always destined
to end in Blood and pain the man with
the runic tattoo was unarmed the only
thing he carried was his regrets the
warrior eyes full of burning Fury drew
his sword and not long after a head hit
the floor who are these two strange men
and what is the significance of this
fatal meeting in our own Universe these
two may never meet again but that
doesn't mean there isn't a universe out
there where they will and it is that
Universe where today's tale Springs from
the story between these two began a long
long time ago when they were both set on
a course of Destruction but to learn how
these two finally met once again we only
need to go back a few days while they
seem more human than a lot of beings
under the SCP foundation's watchful eyes
there's no doubt that these two are
anomalous they're known as SCP 073 and
SCP 076 but better known as Cain and
Abel from the name alone most people
with a basic knowledge of the Bible
could tell that these two have a
connection but the particulars were
largely a mystery to the foundation they
wanted to know how much of the story was
actually true SCP researchers approached
SCP 073 AKA Kane and asked if he'd be
interested in reuniting with his brother
one last time it took Cain 3 Days To
answer yes but on one condition that he
was the only person who could abort the
mission the foundation over this
requirement for 3 days before the 05
Council finally made a decision cross
testing approved these two brothers
separated by Millennia would finally
meet again and the SCP Foundation would
get to watch what happened when they did
of course for safety reasons the cross
test would take place in 076 containment
facility a Bedrock chamber 200 M Beneath
the Sea that would be the closest thing
to Safe this fateful meeting could ever
be though safe was really a a relative
term when it came to SCP
076 his Escape attempts were as frequent
and unpredictable as they were deadly
and everyone who'd ever worked with him
knew exactly why to the untrained eye it
would seem strange to create such a
complex facility for a 3M squared Stone
Cube known as SCP
07601 but the cube isn't what's being
locked up here the real danger comes
from the corpse stored inside known as
SCP
076-2
but better known as Abel he's a lean
Olive skinned man who appears to be in
his late 20s but his most distinct
physical features the fact he's covered
in an elaborate network of Arcane and
occult tattoos largely of scowling
demonic faces similar to those found on
members of the Yakuza whenever Abel's
corpse reanimates as it does at random
intervals everyone in his vicinity is in
terrible danger he's capable of pulling
bladed weapons out of miniature
dimensional riffs that appear around him
though he does this so quickly that it
seems as though the weapons are simply
materializing in his hands despite the
increasingly complex efforts to contain
him Abel has been able to breach
containment and go on Brutal Rampages
multiple times killing scores of
foundation Personnel in the process Abel
possesses superhuman strength speed and
durability during prior containment
breaches he was able to shrug off rounds
from 50 caliber machine guns he's torn
through reinforced steel doors he's even
swatted bullets from both hands hand
guns and assault rifles out of the air
with a length of Steel rebar only
killing him can truly end one of these
Rampages in the foundation has had to go
to terrifying lengths in order to
achieve this during past containment
breaches he's been drowned asphyxiated
crushed burned to death with a thermite
grenade directly inserted into his chest
cavity and even disintegrated by the
activation of the facility's onsite
nuclear warhead this may seem like
Overkill but if able were ever to make
his way into a major population Center
the fatalities would be well of biblical
proportions even death can't keep him
down for long his body will rapidly
decompose and reappear intact with an
SCP
07601 there's no telling when he'll
reawaken and his periods of inactivity
can range from hours to years because of
this he must be constantly observed by
guards highly proficient in close combat
and always ready to go toe-to-toe with
perhaps the most dangerous melee
combatant in history he's such a
proficient killer that there was once a
project aimed at weaponizing AEL but
this turned out to be a disastrous
failure for the foundation when they ran
out of missions to give him Abel's
thirst for blood caused him to turn his
blade on his allies with no remorse
hacking them up with the same ruthless
abandon he gave his assigned enemies
interestingly Abel does seem to have a
twisted sense of Honor he has respect
for combatants capable of providing him
with a real Challenge and has even
expressed concern for guards he
considers to be respectable adversaries
but don't be fooled there is no
reasoning with AEL either you kill him
or he kills you and trust us he's much
better at it than you are while he's
Often overshadowed by world-ending
anomalies or more talkative Mass Killers
like SCP 682 Abel is one of the most
deadly creatures known to the foundation
ael's counterpart 073 is an entirely
different story despite his namesake
being the first biblical murderer this
Cain is a far more enigmatic figure a
tall man in his early 30s appearing to
be of Middle Eastern descent he has two
very notable physical characteristics
the untranslated Sumerian symbol
tattooed on his forehead and the fact
that several of his body parts namely
his arms legs spinal cord and shoulder
blades have been replaced by mysterious
Prosthetics of Unknown Origin unlike
Abel Cain is polite non-confrontational
articulate and communicative he's even
allowed to wander the facility he's
housed in Freely though with certain
regulations namely that Cain is never
permitted to come into contact with
plant life or uncovered ground this is
because in spite of the fact C doesn't
appear to Harbor any malicious intent
direct contact with him causes plants to
wither and die and the ground to become
infertile if Cain was ever introduced
into a natural environment again he
could unwittingly cause an ecological
catastrophe with his mere presence in
that sense he could almost be as
dangerous to large populations as able
however Kane's danger to Flora is only
one of his several anomalous qualities
another is extraordinary mental
capabilities and a near Perfect Memory
his memory and ability to recall is so
good that some Foundation Personnel have
suggested using Kane's mind as a kind of
backup server for the foundation's
collective knowledge but perhaps his
most well-known anomalous trait is his
ability to act as a kind of a mortal
human voodoo doll that's right any
damage inflicted on Cane causes no
permanent injury to him and is reflected
back on the perpetrator while Cain has
remarked on still being able to feel the
pain of these assaults he's functionally
Immortal this damage reflecting ability
has even made performing certain kinds
of tests impossible as doctors
attempting to draw blood from Cain have
found that their sample was actually
their own blood and their skin exhibited
The Telltale bruising and puncture marks
of blood testing but of most interest to
the the foundation right now was the
fact that Cain has shown prior knowledge
of Abel however he was Ki when
questioned he refused to add any
additional information and commented
that it would be best if he and Abel
were never brought into contact but what
does never really mean when you live
forever Cain finally did agree to the
test and while nobody know what caused
C's change of heart the foundation knew
better than to push him and potentially
get the entire Mission scrapped Cain was
taken from his facility and transported
to the access point of Abel's underwater
prison the experiment's design was
simple Cain would occupy a temporary
residence in Abel's containment facility
until he next reanimated at which point
the interaction between them would be
closely observed perhaps it would take
weeks months or even years before Abel
once again awoke and left his Cube but
when he did Cain would be there
thankfully as Cain whispered soothing
words into Abel's tomb the resurrection
took only minutes if you were expecting
a heartwarming reunion think again Cain
tried to apologize but Abel immediately
struck him with a decapitating blow
which due to kan's damage reflecting
properties caused him to sever his own
head instead Cain remained at ael's side
as he regenerated and as soon as Abel
did he immediately tried killing Cain
again it went on like this again and
again and again it was an arduous
process and eventually even Abel began
to Tire of it the duo fell into a
cheerful Embrace Abel asked his brother
why he killed him so long ago and Cain
apologized saying it was the actions of
a younger and more foolish man in that
moment the two finally reconciled and
having fulfilled their bargain with
their creator both finally crumbled into
dust Peace at Last as we said this
didn't happen to the Canan Abel of our
universe but when universes are more
numerous than grains of sand in an
endless desert such a thing has indeed
happen Somewhere Out There perhaps in a
Kinder Universe than our own we can only
hope that Cain and Abel May someday get
to meet and find the same resolution but
until then these brothers will remain
one of the most dangerous and
fascinating Duos in the foundation's
catalog the esteemed Doctor Thomas
morstead entered the cell of the anomaly
he'd been warned and even chastised by
by his colleagues but who in the
foundation could tell him what to do he
was the best at what he did maybe the
greatest in the whole history of the
foundation as he entered the room SCP
049 bid him welcome cordial as always so
polite in fact that you'd never guess
you were talking to a killer Dr morstead
knew the truth of what he was dealing
with but he also believed he could get
through to
049 calm him exercise the devil from him
it was the meeting of two great minds
one of them human one of them part human
part something that has never been clear
it was to be a battle of wits and like
so many great battles this one would
turn into a massacre before we get to
that fiful meeting there are some things
you should know about the anomaly known
as SCP 049 if you saw him in the street
the first thing you'd think of is
playing because 049 always looked the
same a man dressed in black robes with a
plague doctor's mask but this wasn't a
costume that could be taken off in fact
it wasn't a costume at all it was him
the robes had grown out of him like an
exoskeleton that horrible mask with the
pointed nose wasn't covering his face it
was his face a kind of shell that had
seemingly sprouted from bone the first
reports came during World War II in a
picturesque town in the south of France
called montal people had begun going
missing children disappeared from their
beds in the middle mid of the night and
weren't seen again adults went to the
market and never returned local
authorities searched high and low they
scoured nearby woods and dragged the
rivers but nothing was found because
what was happening wasn't Criminal there
was no clue they could stumble upon or
eyewitness who would break the case no
this was something else something that
the town's folk could never understand
word spread and that's when a search and
Discovery team was sent from the
foundation it was a cold Dark Night in
January of 19 1941 when the team found
what they were looking for they walked
through the open door of a small house
located not too far from the grand
chatau thatle to find a mass man sitting
next to an open fire and he wasn't alone
the floor around him looked like it was
moving upon closer inspection the team
saw that the floor was covered with ring
grasping bodies it's patience as it
called them be venu shoa said the thing
welcome to my home those so-called
patients craw towards the team intented
seemed to cause harm the hostiles now
known as SCP
049-2 were deemed dangerous and had to
be eliminated a sight it seemed that
didn't bother 049 in the slightest it
just sat there occasionally looking up
from writing notes in a leatherbound
book as his patience were gunned down
once the Carnage ended it simply closed
its book stood up and allowed itself to
be escorted away and that's the story of
how 049 ended up at the facility
becoming a guest of sorts staying in a
standard secure humanoid containment
cell research sector 02 site 19 the few
that came into contact with 049 remarked
that it was a pleasure for them with its
impeccable manners vast knowledge of
medicine and human anatomy sharp tongue
and stinging W they almost became
Spellbound listening to it caught in the
throws of its charms until with the
Simple Touch of its hand it would drain
the life from them that's why SCP 049
was classified as a
that's why armed guards were always
stationed outside itself cell it's why
doctors took great precautions when in
its presence and it's why Dr morstead
should have known better remember when
049 was discovered in France it
willingly went with the team like it was
happy it had been found as if it had
planned its own capture when it arrived
at the facility it didn't act like it
was contained against its will it was
like it was returning home initial
findings as to the biology of 049 were
that it didn't require any sustenance at
all not not even water it seemed content
to be left alone with its notebooks it
did not object when it was asked if it
could share some of its notes and gladly
handed over its journals but upon
examination it was discovered that they
were written in the language that no
linguist or cryptologist has so far been
able to translate it's apparent that 049
derives much satisfaction from seeing
so-called experts struggle over its text
unable to read those notes a long line
of doctors visited 049 in itself cell
each fascinated by what they beh it was
learned that it has traveled the globe
it speaks many languages but prefers to
speak what it calls Le long de French it
asked for only one thing warm-blooded
animals the facility agreed to supply
049 with various kinds including rabbits
cattle and even an ape on one occasion
just like with humans it could kill the
animals with a mere Touch of its hand
sucking the life right out of them but
that wasn't even the most incredible
part soon those animals would rise again
as if reanim ated by 049 they would
become for all intents and purposes the
Living Dead and they were hostile after
several unfortunate incidents they were
taken from the cell the moment they
arose and disposed of in the incinerator
this was not to the liking of 049 who
would claim it had cured the animals for
it the world was sick it saw plague and
pestilence everywhere and the meaning of
its existence was to rid the world of
disease humans it said contained a virus
and had to be cleansed in the first days
after arriving at the facility 049
didn't seem to pose a threat to humans
it was quite friendly in fact it seemed
aware of the fear it caused in staff and
would often go out of its way to make
them feel comfortable and safe this was
a ruse of course or a Canard as 049 like
to say it had no intention to help
humans no it had come for humans it
wasn't trapped it had set a trap one of
the first people to truly upset 049 was
Dr Raymond Ham a well-respected
physician that had twice been a
contender for the Nobel Prize for his
more mainstream work what had confused
Dr Ham the most was not 049 cloth-like
exoskeleton or even his ability to
reanimate the dead but the bag that it
used 049 was somehow able to pull a
seemingly endless supply of surgical
tools from that bag sometimes it would
even pull out objects that Were Somehow
larger than the bag itself it was as if
the bag connected to somewhere else and
that's what Dr Ham wanted to talk about
on that fateful day with 049 on one side
of the cell and Dr Ham on the other he
asked how is it that you can produce a
great quantity of tools from that bag
I've observed you and it seems to me
that you are doing The Impossible dear
doctor replied 049 The Scourge The Great
dying cannot be fought with a handful of
toys my bag is merely the product of my
imagination it gives me what I require
you dear sir it seems are are limited by
your imagination it stopped for a second
or two and stared at Dr Ham I detect you
are unwell it said in a voice not as
amiable as before it's just a cold said
the doctor ah just a cold if you had
seen what I have seen you would not
utter such insulting words Dr Ham pulled
out some papers from a briefcase and
approached 049 holding them close enough
so it could read them you see said Dr
Ham pointing to the results on the paper
those animals you say you cured they
were not diseased they were perfectly
healthy before they died and your
so-called cure it turned them into
something quite terrible we found that
if they were left alone they began to
eat each other and then themselves 049
did not respond and after a brief pause
said only a good day to your doctor
please close the door on your way out
you should get some rest ham refused to
go and instead turned the conversation
to this real interest the bag demanding
that 049 let him see inside of it very
well doctor 049 said in private 049
began to pull a series of long metal
poles out of its bag followed by a
rolled up curtain that it hung between
them creating a kind of medical tent
around Dr Ham it seemed to stare for
just a moment into the observation
camera outside of itself before whipping
the curtain Shut Dr Ham was discovered 3
hours later crawling around the floor of
049 cell now another mindless Undead
when he was retrieved by security 049
didn't even look up from his notebook
book Dr Ham didn't get the incinerator
treatment but he did receive a fatal
dose of drugs a mercy a removal team was
sent to 049 cell but it had said there
was no need for special extraction
techniques it would go willingly
wherever they wanted to go it was not it
said an enemy of the people the
hypocritic oath forbids me to hurt a
human being it said while walking to the
interrogation Center my only desire is
to offer you my services and expertise
the floors and walls of the
interrogation Center room were painted a
bright white even the table was white
which contrasted with 049 a mass of
black sitting in the middle of the room
during the interrogation it refused to
admit or even accept that it had killed
Dr Ham I cured him I removed the
pestilence from his body it said it was
later asked if it regretted its actions
to which it replied well good sir one
always regrets the loss of a colleague
for any reason but I stand by my actions
the pestilence must be abated before it
is too late every 2 weeks from that
point 049 was given animals the
scientists at the facility observed it
time and again touching the animals
killing them before producing a saw or
scalpel and opening them up organs would
be carefully removed with perfect
Precision it was astounding to even
train surgeons just how talented 049 was
I require a close relative of yours said
049 one day to a young Doctor Who
expressed shock that it was asked for
one of the doctor's family members I
mean a great a said 049 not your dear
Aunt there were several instances of 049
displaying a crude sense of humor staff
would almost forget that the thing that
they were talking to wasn't human almost
and it was Dr Thomas morstead that had
supplied the great apes Aang tanks in
fact that had been rescued from the
rainforests of Borneo only to be taken
to 049 South then one day something
changed 049 told Dr morstead that its
work was done that it accomplished what
it had wanted to do and could someone
remove the cured animal from itself I
think you'd find that it's quite the
work of art a Triumph 049 said through
the intercom when the removal team
entered the cell they found the
orangutang or what was left of it it was
lying in the corner of the cell the top
of its skull had been removed leaving
its brain Exposed on its face was the
expression of relaxation and from its
mouth it issued very soft squeaks like
that of an infant 049 said tell Dr Mora
that its rage mechanism M no longer
exists I've removed the amydala and made
some changes to the hypothalamus and
lyic system it is cured and quite
harmless the next day Dr morstead
announced that he wanted to visit 049
cell himself after which he heard A
Chorus of disapproval from his
colleagues all telling him that 049 was
now too dangerous Dr Ham was sick
replied Morad and 049 has assured us
that he would never take another human
life he's never lied to us and I'm going
to take him at his word it appeared that
049 had created the perfect specimen so
what was next Dr morstead had to know
everyone is sick 049 told Dr morstead
after the two had talked for a couple of
minutes the great pandemic has started
fear not doctor I have a cure no longer
will you humans spread your disease I'm
afraid you are wrong replied the doctor
this pandemic you speak of does not
exist we can happily live with our
pathogens we have done so for Millennial
Dr morstead became angry that he
couldn't get through to 049 I'm afraid
you are suffering from paranoia it is
you who need to be cured you have no
idea said 049 standing up what are you
doing shouted morstad you promis you
wouldn't hurt a human again I'm not
hurting you I'm healing you 049 said and
leapt across the room in a Flash placing
a hand on the doctor's head morstead
slumped to the ground they were being
watched in the observation room and this
had gone too far he had to be moved to
the containment cells permanently mobile
task force Epsilon 11 was right on the
scene and burst through the door no
imagination 049 said to himself those
humans have no imagination at all he
began walking towards the task force who
opened fire on the anomaly but the
bullets bounced off its black code and
mask SCP 049 calmly touched each of the
members of the task force one by one
draining the life from them the last one
standing stopped firing and attempted to
run but again 049 leapt across the room
black cap billowing out behind him and
gently touched the man causing him to
drop to the floor 049 stepped over the
bodies of the Fallen team and walked out
of the containment cell the full details
of what happened next are available only
to the 05 Council what are sometimes
called the overseers the redacted report
that is available reads standard secure
humanoid containment cell research
sector 02 site 19 subject SCP 049 date
of breach redacted uid class SCP 049
breach cell and subsequently gained
access to adjoining rooms and nearby
buildings breach lasted approximately 3
days and 5 hours total casualties
redacted with redacted number of
survivors requiring incineration therapy
course of action Department of science
Alchemy division suggested injecting
anti-trans morphi disinfectant into
class D former prisoners who were
transported to site and allowed them to
come into contact with SCP 049 SCP
failed to reanimate injected prisoners
and cure them SCP 049 9 acknowledged
this failure and surrendered to mobile
task force alpha 1 SCP 049 then
requested to be contained present
containment under responsibility of
redacted redacted present location of
SCP 049 redacted end of report a veteran
worker of the SCP Foundation sits at his
terminal performing one of the most
critical tasks in the entire
organization creating a file for an as
yet undescribed SCP but there's
something terribly wrong his eyes are
glazed over his mouth hangs open is this
a zombie or a trained Foundation
researcher what is going on like any
large International Organization it
takes more than just the exciting
action-filled jobs to keep the wheels
turning at the SCP Foundation sure the
head researchers guards mobile task
force soldiers and members of the 05
command get all the praise but a legion
of number crunchers cleaners and paper
pushers are equally important one such
person was archivist Walter Banbridge
who had been tasked with digitizing some
of the older records that the foundation
had on file it was when he was
innocently recording the details on SCP
050 through
060 that he first came under the strange
and startling effects of SCP
055 but the most peculiar part as with
all incidents of SCP 055 anomalous
effects taking hold is that Walter had
no idea that any of it was happening in
his new digitized filing system he first
took note of SCP 053 uclid class also
known as the young girl this anomaly was
a seemingly normal human female child
who provoked homicidal Insanity in those
directly exposed to her then SCP 054
safe class a non-aggressive humanoid
female made entirely of as well as
biologically and chemically identical to
regular spring water next SCP 056 uclid
Class A being that changes form to suit
its environment but only when all
observers lose focus of it and then SCP
057 safe class an underground chamber
that crushes the humans who walk within
it was at this point that Walter
received a concerned message from one of
his superiors at site 19 Mr kovat the
message praised the thorough
digitization of the other anomalies
records but was confused about why
Walter had left out any mention of SCP
055 immediately Walter was embarrassed
how could he have forgotten SCP
055 that iconic anomaly known for well
he couldn't quite say off the top of his
head but he'd be sure to look into it a
quick trip to the site9 archive showed
him that there was actually quite a
hefty file on the nature of SCP
055 which must have been the result of a
huge number of studies what struck him
as strange was that all the files were
filled out in pen rather than being
typed up like a traditional file the
majority of these notes were written in
shorthand too as though they were
frantically taken during the tests
themselves on extremely short notice
there weren't even any redactions Walter
made a mental note of what he had seen
put the file back in its proper place
and headed back to his computer terminal
however after writing in an almost
trans-like State he looked back on his
work to see that he had written an entry
on SCP 58 a giant evil Bine heart with
insect legs and a scorpion Stinger
strange he thought that's when Walter
got a call from Mr kovat on his
foundation issue phone and he didn't
sound happy he'd given Walter direct
instructions to go back and digitize the
files on
055 and instead he'd been working on 058
what was the meaning of This Walter was
typically an extremely loyal and
diligent employee but the verbal barrage
from his supervisor had him considering
talking back just this once and hoping
it didn't get him demoted to d-class and
thrown into 682s Acid Bath for playtime
Walter G picked up some courage and
interrupted Mr kovach's rant to ask if
he had any idea what SCP 055 actually
was the line went silent for a moment
then his supervisor spoke again this
time with less confidence uh of course I
can tell you about SCP
055 uh it's a classic one of the first
100 how could you forget it's uh or you
know it's think it's the one with um
another long pause as Mr kovat seemed to
search for the words but instead just
trailed off into silence knowing that
some of the anomalies on file were
dangerous mimetic hazards Walter was
worried for a moment that he may have
accidentally killed his boss by getting
him to think too hard about SCP 055 he
asked if Mr kovan was okay and finally
got a reply I'm sorry I seem to have
zoned out for a second there what were
we talking about again but this time it
was Walter who couldn't answer he had no
idea at all what the two of them were
discussing just moments ago he felt
disoriented and kind of sick like they'd
taken some low-level amnestics Mr kovat
told Walter to get back to his filing
duties and they'd speak later Walter
then checked the messages he'd received
from Mr kovat earlier and there it was
plain as day you miss
055 go back and digitize that before
proceeding Mr K but Walter had never
even heard of an SCP 055 if such an
anomaly even existed what was going on
here in that moment Walter realized he
was dealing with something much Stranger
Than Just a standard digitization job
after all how could he properly complete
his duties if SCP 055 seemed to be
impossible to speak write or even even
think about unless you were directly
observing it at that moment Walter had
to know and ask around the entirety of
site 19 to find the answers if he had to
sadly for Walter he was about to embark
on a much more challenging task than he
could have ever imagined to paraphrase a
supposed quote from Socrates all I know
is that I know nothing and that's also
about the extent of the knowledge we
have on SCP
055 also known as the anti-an and the
self- keeping secret what does it look
like when and how was it obtained by the
foundation what are its anomalous
abilities is this thing dangerous we may
never know because the only anomalous
ability of SCP 055 that we're aware of
is the fact that nobody is capable of
retaining any information about it it's
crucial to note that whatever 055 is it
isn't invisible or
Indescribable Foundation Personnel are
perfectly capable of of entering its
containment chamber and observing it
without incident but mere minutes after
leaving the chamber any memories of the
particulars of 055 seemed to
spontaneously erase themselves hence the
self- keeping secret but this didn't
deter Walter perhaps his greatest
Advantage was that he didn't know enough
about the thing he was investigating to
know how futile his mission was he
wanted to know the unknowable and a
pesky issue like impossibility wouldn't
stop him he'd to whoever he needed to at
site 19 to get the answers he needed of
course most people had no knowledge of
the mysterious anomaly the common
response he got back from his colleagues
was 055 do we even have a 055 while the
realization of sudden memory loss or the
realization of 055 existence has been
known to cause momentary stress there
are no known long-term physical or
mental effects from 055 anomalous
abilities it's a fleeting idea in in its
purest form like forgetting why you
walked into a room 055 could be the most
harmless object on the foundation's
roster or the most deadly either way we
just don't know at times Walter worried
he was going insane 055 and everything
related to it was gaslighting him was
055 even real the one thing that proved
to him that 055 must have existed is
that its containment chamber existed
according to the official records kept
by the foundation on the site 19
containment facilities 055 is kept in a
5x5 x 2.5 M Square Room constructed of
50 ft thick cement with a faraday cage
surrounding the cement walls the report
continues that access is via a heavy
containment door measuring 2x 2.5 M
constructed on bearings to ensure door
closes and locks automatically unless
held open deliberately zero 55 cell is
one of the few to have no posted
security guards and any Personnel
working on other scps in the area are
ordered to remain at least 50 ft from
the geometric Center of 055 cell where
the anomaly itself is kept when he tried
to explore further why the cell was
constructed in this manner he found that
surprise surprise nobody knew 055 was an
anomaly whose containment requirements
were so mysterious that it automatically
netted itself a better class designation
after all how can you properly contain
something you can't even hope to
comprehend there were plenty of rumors
about the true nature of
055 some of the more conspiratorial
Minds at site 19 theorize that 055 was
actually an autonomous or remotely
controlled spy inserted into the site to
observe Foundation operations or even
Humanity as a whole if you're on the
more paranoid end of the psychological
Spectrum this Theory makes total sense
an anomaly that's physically impossible
to remember even when writings and
pictures on the subject exist would be a
perfect spy however this was all
ultimately little more than speculation
Walter was barely any further along than
when he started there were multiple
points in his investigations where
Walter seriously considered giving up
until finally he had a major
breakthrough Dr Bartholomew Hughes and
Dr John marich were two scientists that
had performed EX ensive Research into
055 and who Walter hoped might have the
answers he sought about the self-
keeping secret these scientists were the
first to discover the antimimetic nature
of 055 performing numerous tests on
d-class Personnel to see if it was
possible to create feasible written
records sketches or any other records or
Impressions that could bypass its
anomalous effects the disorienting
memory ruining effects of 055 also
extend to any materials concerning
055 it seems to be a truly uncrackable
code but Dr Hughes may have finally
found some cracks in the armor for
starters the fact that we're able to
remember that 055 is an anti-mimetic is
an ironic exception to its antimimetic
qualities this Revelation also inspired
another realization from Dr Hughes would
it be possible to discover more about
055 from the process of deduction rather
than the typical induction in other
words could they possibly learn about
055 by figuring out all the things it
isn't rather than what it is Dr Mar
designed an experiment with Dr Hughes to
explore this Theory they designed the
experiment around a simple question is
055 not spherical in designing the
question to specifically find out what
055 isn't they hope to subvert the
anomaly's antimimetic powers Walter was
fascinated by this potential method of
getting answers maruk and Hughes found
that while the questioning process for
those exposed was often arduous and
frustrating they could now definitely
say that
055 is not a sphere it is theoretically
possible to discover the true nature of
055 by an almost endless barrage of
deductive questions the we command would
authorize the resources for such
extensive testing is still an open
question Walter in his desperation
begged marich and Hughes for clearance
to view 055 himself the Curiosity had
become too great during his search to
just walk away with the single fact that
055 wasn't spherical he needed to see
this thing and after several weeks of
filling out forms and cutting red tape
his wish was finally granted Walter
Banbridge was allowed a private audience
with SCP
055 the subject of his monthlong
obsession Outsiders observe that Walter
spent just over an hour in the
containment chamber taking photos
drawing sketches writing down notes
recording audio logs and reciting memory
pneumonics he was pulling out every stop
to counteract the anti-mimetic effects
of the self- keeping secret he was
adamant that he would not be defeated by
his non-spherical Nemesis not after all
this time and effort once his time in
the 055 containment chamber was over he
retired back to his office to finally
digitize his exhaustive findings so that
his supervisor Mr kovat would finally
get off his back Walter smiled took a
deep breath and began to type SCP 059
ker class this anomaly is a radioactive
mineral that emits a unique radiation
known as Delta radiation exposure to
this radiation has caused strange fungal
growths on the
infected wait what was this supposed to
be about again oh well it couldn't have
been that important SCP 682 must be
destroyed as soon as possible so Begins
the SCP Foundation file on the dreaded
SCP 682 a highly intelligent reptilian
monster that has despite the
foundation's best efforts proved
impossible to kill it may not be the
most dangerous SCP out there considering
that some are capable of eliminating
entire realities but it's one of the
most iconic and you've probably heard
tales of the monster that death forgot
and you know exactly why everyone is so
afraid of the so-called hard tokill
reptile it's been subject Ed to some of
the most deadly weapons and traps the
foundation could devise and survived
attacks from some of its deadliest
fellow scps but before we tell you about
the foundations many failed
assassination attempts against the
so-called hard- tokill reptile we need a
little more groundwork on what this
creature even is the first thing to know
about SCP 682 is that this thing wants
you and everything you know dead unlike
some other creatures like scp096 and SCP
173 which are murder but exhibit no real
higher processing skills SCP 682
possesses cunning Advanced reasoning and
even human level logical intelligence
SCP 682 can engage you in conversation
but just talking to the creature calmly
and cordially will sometimes cause it to
enter its rage state where it becomes
even more dangerous and volatile the
Beast is perpetually kept in a tank of
powerful hydrochloric acid melting its
tissue to prevent it from reaching its
full potential and going on a rampage
the creature's most terrifying asset and
the reason it's proven impossible to
terminate thus far is its incredible
adaptability to any and all external
stimuli 682 is a reactive being capable
of not only surviving and regenerating
from all attacks but often incorporating
those attacks into its own wide Arsenal
in other words if you're hoping to kill
this thing you better kill it on the
first hit cuz if you don't you better
believe it's going to hit you back a 100
times
harder this brings us to the main event
some of the SCP foundation's most
ambitious and frightening attempts to
terminate SCP 682 or even understand how
it could theoretically be terminated
there are quite literally too many
unsuccessful attempts for us to list
them all here so think of this as a
highlight reel of the foundation's most
prominent failures 682 was first cross
tested with SCP 017 a humanoid Shadow
entity shown to be able to consume
matter with its shadows and leave no
traces behind test on tissue samples
from 682 showed that SCP 017 was able to
consume said tissues with no adverse
effects however when SCP 017 was placed
into the containment chamber with the
actual creature 682 let out a horrific
Roar that was so loud it damaged nearby
audio equipment SCP 017 fled to the
corner of the room and 682 in its rage
State attempted to breach containment
agents managed to suppress and remove
the creature but no meaningful damage
was logged attempt failed SCP 173 the
killer statue was later brought in
hoping that it's thus far impeccable
track record for killing what hold
strong the second that 173 was
introduced into the testing area 682
retreated to the far wall and began
screeching intensely it was intelligent
enough to know what it was dealing with
here while the researchers and guards
expected an instantaneous reaction there
was actually a stalemate for over 6
hours as 682 stared at 173 continuously
eventually the tie was broken when
agents shot out 682s eyes with high
caliber sniper rifles breaking the line
of sight and causing 173 to attack
though 682 sustained damage to several
parts of its body while its eyes
regenerated the creature was not killed
it then regenerated a number of eyes all
over its body covered in a clear armored
carpas that made them resistant to
bullets the stalemate continued for an
additional 12 hours as 682 maintained
Perpetual eye contact act 173 was
eventually removed from the containment
unit and the mission was aborted attempt
failed in their desperation the SCP
Foundation restored to bringing in
another dangerous and seemingly
unkillable monster to take on 682 scp096
also known as the shy guy as astute SCP
fans will already know this being kills
anything that sees its face with no
known exceptions and when it enters its
attack mode it's thought to be quite
literally
Unstoppable or at least it was while
scp096 was able to destroy 85% of 682s
original body mass during their 27-hour
battle it was left mentally broken
wounded and huddled in the corner to
this day if ever confronted with SCP 682
the shy guy reacts in pure Terror
turning away and clawing at its own face
attempt failed during a deadly
Containment Breach SCP 682 also went
head-to-head organically with another
iconic SCP Hall of Famer SCP 106 also
known as the old man the old man and a
shape-shifting psionic anomaly known as
SCP 953 broke into 682s containment cell
the old man pulled both of his fellow
anomalous combatants into his pocket
Dimension to continue the battle on his
terms however despite losing 67% of his
body mass during the ensuing pocket
Dimension Showdown 682 still prevailed
with the old man eventually fleeing back
to his cell and 953 being collected and
taken away by agents once again SCP 682
continued to hold the title but it
wasn't just cross testing experiments
intentional or otherwise the SCP
foundation's quest to kill 682 LED them
to a number of more conventional murder
methods all with varying degrees of
success due to SCP 682 highly adaptive
abilities some methods were discounted
from the outset for example launching a
powerful thermonuclear missile at the
creature was soundly rejected by 05
command on the premise that if the
creature wasn't destroyed and evolved to
the point where it could shrug off nukes
Humanity would be pretty much done for
other ideas were abandoned just for
being too ridiculous such as one
researcher suggestion to fly the
creature through the air and drop it
from a considerable height hoping to
kill it with a high altitude impact I'm
not sure we even need to tell you why
that's a terrible idea but during the
experiments on SCP 682 the studies range
from honest to encom to straight up
evil one guest researcher fed two small
innocent children to the creature just
to see what would happen he was then
himself fed to the creature for a
sadistic Behavior which was viewed as
getting in the way of his professional
conduct after all the foundation is
meant to be cold not cruel it was SCP
682 that had the Monopoly on cruelty
mimic kill agents were a resounding
failure they attempted to dismember 682
with a powerful laser only to have the
creature develop reflective services
that displaced the beam and caused
catastrophic damage to the area around
it they attempted to kill the creature
by sucking all the air out of its
containment facility and create a vacuum
but it expelled a dangerous gaseous
compound that reacted violently and
exploded when air was once again
introduced into the room the foundation
used High Precision Blades to slice SCP
682 into approximately 12,000 pieces
then separated these pieces
unsurprisingly by this point this
attempt also failed the 12,000 pieces
formed a short while later into the
fully operational killing machine we all
know in fear in one particularly
frightening display of intelligence and
adaptability the foundation attempted to
kill 682 with extreme heat but it
shielded Itself by developing a second
car Pace composed of solid helium when
Personnel entered the room following the
failed attempt on the creature's life it
shattered its helium carapace into
deadly shards that fired around the room
and shredded all Foundation Personnel in
attendance it had set a trap and that
trap had been wildly successful the
creature's ability to adapt to seemingly
any offense is unparalleled to the point
where Foundation staff have no idea how
to classify this creature whether it's
organic inorganic or even alive at all
based on any definitions we could
understand at every turn the creature
just raised more questions what is it is
it possible to destroy it at all by any
means who was even trying to kill who
here because it certainly seemed like
SCP 682 had a masterful KD ratio by now
more extreme Feats of cross testing
continued in the foundation's growing
desperation to eliminate this monster
SCP 162 which is a hypnotic ball of
sharp objects Hooks and high tension
fishing line was introduced to 682s
containment cell the hooks latched onto
the creature and tore huge portions off
including its entire lower jaw and one
of its limbs however 682 was still able
to breach containment kill 11 people and
badly wound 86 others it regenerated its
severe injuries in no time the Beast was
even taken to the domain of the gate
Guardian one of the proposals for SCP
001 the guardian had a flaming sword
hotter than the sun capable of
destroying its Targets on an atomic
level naturally SCP 682 survived and
regenerated perhaps the most fascinating
cross test of all was between 682 and
SCP
053 who manifests as a kind innocent
little girl with the unfortunate
condition of causing homicidal
Tendencies and all who come into contact
with her for more than 10 minutes the
people with these Tendencies would then
attempt to harm the girl but would
immediately drop dead shortly after
leaving the girl intact the researchers
present anticipated two possible
outcomes here the optimistic outcome in
which 682 enters a rage State attacked
053 and died for good and the realistic
outcome in which 682 attacked 053
possibly experiencing some minor injury
or nothing at all and 053 had to be
removed from the containment cell
but that didn't happen what did occur
was considerably more shocking than any
kind of violence when 053 entered 682s
containment chamber the monster became
uncharacteristically docile researchers
and staff were baffled and watched with
amazement as 053 approached the
terrifying Immortal Mass murdering
monster and began to play with it 682
even allowed 053 to draw on its face
with crayons researchers thought they
must have been dreaming seeing this
surreal display play out 053 even
appeared to have affection for this
unkillable misanthrope it was a single
act in defiance of everything they
thought they knew when Foundation
Personnel entered the containment cell
to separate the two 682 went ballistic
and killed multiple guards 053 also wept
sad at being separated from her new
friend to this day despite further
testing the foundation has no idea how
or why this happened like many details
surrounding SCP 682 it shrouded in
deeply frustrating
mystery and so the tale of SCP 682
continues in spite of the foundation's
best efforts the monster continues to
breach containment and Slaughter with
some regularity taking out its seemingly
Limitless hatred for not only human
beings but anything that dares drop
breath nobody knows where exactly the
creature is from what its true nature is
or why its ability to adapt and
regenerate far exceeds any known
organism on this planet perhaps one day
through enough research and cross
testing we can someday answer these
questions with scientific Precision but
until then we only have one answer
hatred Never Dies a month ago Dr Robert
Maxwell was a senior researcher working
at the facility but a tragic mistake had
cost the lives of several of his
co-researchers now he was being led down
o Bleak hallway in armed biocontainment
Area 14 a rifle wielding guard flanking
him on either side the once Rising
researcher had a very different title
now D
8724 he had been made a d-class
Personnel a death
sentence however as the guards led him
to his possible demise he wasn't dressed
in the typical d-class orange jumpsuit
no he was dressed in frilly Roco dining
wear more typical of 18th century France
if anything Dr Maxwell looked like he
was on his way to meet royalty and in a
sense he was the former researcher had
begged for any other assignment but the
site director insisted on committing Dr
Maxwell to tea time with SCP
082 he'd always been the talkative type
so the two would make a perfect pairing
and if the creature found him
sufficiently amusing then Maxwell might
even leave the containment cell alive he
had heard Legends of the giant creature
they called the cannibal Maxwell hoped
that they were just stories Dr Maxwell
was pushed by the guards into a large
luxuriously appointed room and the doors
were locked behind him he felt like a
child surrounded by freakishly large
furniture and 10t high ceilings the fog
of obnoxious floral perfumes couldn't
fully cover up the pervasive smell of
death that lingered in the cavernous
Halls of0 82's Palace thanks to an
elaborate ruse conducted by the
foundation SCP 082 believed he was the
King of France and that his containment
cell was a palace where he remained for
his own safety the creatures continued
good behavior and everyone else's safety
relied on visitors keeping up that lie
Maxwell had never worked in this area of
the facility so a lot of the standard
procedures were new to him still his
Superior had given him a clear directive
talk to the monster communicate with him
be cordial and friendly see if you can
find out more about his mysterious past
and most importantly if you want to
survive don't annoy him the down on his
Lu scientist gulped inside trying to
steady his nerves in this oversized fake
french Palace he just kept thinking
surely he can't be that big he almost
talked himself into believing that the
accounts of the creature were just that
tall tales until a huge figure began
lumbering into the main chamber it was
him SCP 082 also known as Fernand the
cannibal SCP 082 was an 8ft tall hulking
monster built sturdier than the castles
it likes to imagine are its true home
swollen bloated and grossly out of
proportion the creature clocks in at
over 700 lb most of which is pure muscle
that's almost impossible to pierce with
conventional Weaponry SCP 082 stopped
just feet away and stared at Dr Maxwell
with its Beady sunken in eyes like a
hungry rat
just the sight of it struck Terror into
Dr Maxwell's heart but he didn't dare
show his fear instead he remembered his
brief training bowing politely and
forcing a smile referring to the
creature as your highness and profusely
thanking it for granting him an audience
the monster continued staring without
saying anything and then gave a wide
lock jawed grin showing off its huge
teeth it did everything through gritted
teeth except eat and sing
Dr Maxwell hoped he wouldn't be a part
of either activity Fernand gave a low
booming chuckle he thanked Dr Maxwell
for coming to give him some company and
invited him to come further inside and
take a seat adding with a slight Wing
that he won't bite the monster
complained that he so rarely gets
visitors to the Palace these days but he
omitted the fact that the main reason
for this was his tendency to devour them
Maxwell nodded and followed the giant
deeper into its oversized bow he
couldn't help but notice that the
monster's arms looked like huge fleshy
punching bags he knew that if ferand
wanted to he could easily crush him flat
just like he done to so many unfortunate
guards during containment breaches
Ferdinand told Dr Maxwell that he was
thinking of having some decorating work
done the walls of his Palace were
starting to look awfully draft and he
gestured to one covered with a rusty red
streak Maxwell remembered that declass
cleaners were sent into the containment
cell twice a month to tidy any of
ferdinand's messes but they often ended
up becoming one of the messes themselves
the creature encouraged Maxwell to take
a seed at his oversized dining table
while he tended to a pot of what he said
was full of delicious onion soup Maxwell
obliged his host's request and took a
seat at a huge chair that made him look
like a six-year-old sitting at the
grown-ups table meanwhile Ferdinand was
using a huge machete like knife to
cleave onions in half for his bubbling
pot of stew even though Ferd had shown
no signs of outward aggression as he
watched the cannibal hack away at onions
with his enormous knife Maxwell could
feel himself beginning to sweat after
all they didn't call this creature the
cannibal for nothing this was a monster
with a truly horrifying body count
during previous containment breaches it
had taken enough tranquilizer to put
down two elephants to subdue the
creature but not before multiple agents
quite literally lost their heads in the
process ferin was able to bite them off
with one huge Chomp like he was eating a
drumstick snapping right through the
bone with his incredible tooth and jaw
strength surprisingly when he wasn't on
a violent Rampage Foundation researchers
had found SCP 082 to be unusually polite
and forthcoming offering the researchers
plenty of information about himself and
his past the only problem was that
almost everything the creature said was
a complete lie from his time as a
researcher Maxwell knew that there were
only a few Det details about the
creature that could be ascertained for
certain SCP 082 would reliably answer to
the name ferand and genetically
Ferdinand was technically human the
means by which Ferdinand became so
grotesquely huge strong and
cannibalistic are still unknown
Foundation Personnel are still looking
into whether it's due to some kind of
anomalous genetic mutation or by more
Supernatural means all we know is that
he's big unpredictable and extremely
dangerous Dr Robert Maxwell sat
terrified at the dining table of SCP 082
listening to fernand's slightly dull
blade chopped through the final onion
which he then tossed into the boiling
soup feran had switched the topic of
conversation to one of his favorite
fictional characters Hannibal Lecter of
course Hannibal the cannibal isn't quite
so fictional to feram while he's been
shown to be extremely intelligent in
terms of puzzle solving and memory he
seems to have no understanding
understanding of the distinctions
between fiction and reality he assumes
all movies and TV shows are a form of
documentary or reality television and
ever since seeing the Silence of the
Lambs Ferdinand has been eager to meet
with Dr Lecter which he emphasized to
Maxwell over and over since trying to
explain the concept of fiction to
Ferdinand had never previously worked
Maxwell simply told him that Dr Lecter
is extremely busy at the moment but will
visit whenever he gets a chance this
seemed to satisfy fer who placed two
large bowls of steaming soup on the
table before sitting down a little too
close to Maxwell he couldn't help but
notice that the giant cannibal was now
sitting within biting distance and as a
lowly declass nobody would be rushing in
to save him if things went South ferand
began ranting through his clenched teeth
once more occasionally stopping to
consume a hefty spoonful of onion soup
Maxwell was sure to do the same not
wanting to seem anything less than
polite but soon the tenor of first n's
rant began to shift typically the
monster spoke French or heavily accented
English now he was affecting the accent
of a Victorian gentleman peppering a
speech with tell ho and the game is a
foot Maxwell was confused at first but
quickly realized the game Ferdinand was
playing it's well known that Ferdinand
is a pathological liar who likes to play
numerous characters changing his
mannerisms and clothes accordingly these
personas have included a vampire big
bird Andre the Giant Foundation
researcher Dr brigh The Incredible Hulk
Alexander the Great Captain Hook Dr
Frankenstein and Frankenstein's monster
and of course in this case the iconic
fictional detective Sherlock Holmes
fearing for his life in this strange
situation Dr Maxwell did the only thing
he could play along as ferand reeled off
his homesan delusions Maxwell began to
play the role of Dr John Watson asking
follow-up questions and complimenting
ferdinand's impeccable deductive
reasoning and it seemed to be working
Ferdinand played along too acting as
though the two of them really were
Arthur Conan Doyle's crime fighting Duo
towards the end of their game Dr Maxwell
was even starting to enjoy it amazed
that his quick thinking was actually
keeping him safe but just then the
cannibal froze as if in a trance he
locked eyes with Dr Maxwell like a mad
dog that you can't tell if it's going to
bite you or not
he saw the creatur's gargantuan teeth
separating its huge Jaws stretching open
this could surely only mean one thing Dr
Maxwell winced and prepared for death
cursing that all of his quick thinking
had amounted to nothing fand leaned
towards him his gaping ma with its hot
onion scented breath just inches away
from Maxwell and then he began to sing
the cannibal broke into a rockus
Victorian Pub song happy and jovial in
his moment of Terror Dr Maxwell had
forgotten that this was the other reason
SCP 082 opens his nightmarish Jaws
relief washed over him as he knew he was
safe at least for the moment not long
after Foundation guards arrived and
escorted him from the cell leaving the
delusional giant to his own devices back
in the so-called Palace the former
researcher had done it he had bested
Ferdinand the cannibal and hopefully it
would be the last time he'd ever be face
to face with that deranged giant
unfortunately for Dr Robert Maxwell in a
performance review later that week one
of his superiors remarked that Ferdinand
enjoyed his company and he had done a
great job such a good job in fact that
Ferdinand insisted he have Dr Maxwell
for dinner or any other meal for that
matter sometime very
[Music]
soon
on March 15th 2011 Martin Sims was
wandering down the streets of Carson
California his clothes were ragged he
was filthy and gibbering like a madman
with a full beard and long unkempt hair
his body was covered in scars but he
showed no signs of malnutrition what
made Martin's sudden appearance so
remarkable he'd been missing for 3 years
when he was interviewed by police they
asked him where he'd been all this time
they couldn't believe his answer he'd
been trapped in an Ikea since 08 but
this was no ordinary Ikea this was a
dangerous anomaly that would come to be
known as SCP 3008 Martin's strange
answers in his interview were laughed
off by his interviewing officers who
assumed he was either crazy or under the
influence of something but they caught
the attention of an SCP Foundation field
agent embedded in the precinct the
report was passed up the chain to a
local site director who approved a
Detachment of foundation field
operatives to look into Martin's case
while he was reluctant to lead the
foundation agents back to the offending
Ikea the foundation can be extremely
persuasive his screams of please I'm
begging you don't take me back don't
make me go back were noted but
ultimately disregarded when the SCP
Foundation had triangulated the position
of SCP 3008 which was indeed an active
Ikea the entire retail Zone was closed
and barricaded under the pretense of a
severe black mold investation armed
Foundation Personnel also arrived on the
site shortly after based on Martin's
vague statements that there were
creatures of some kind inside due to his
deteriorating mental health Martin was
unable to provide a great deal of lucid
information on the specific traits of
SCP 3008 but one phrase he kept
repeating was bigger on the inside once
researchers were satisfied that Martin
had delivered all the pertinent
information he was able to he was
administered Foundation amnestics to
erase his memory of the last 3 years and
returned to his family a cover story was
formulated Martin had been kidnapped and
abused for 3 years by a mentally
unbalanced St St ER in downtown Carson
he'd been able to escape as said stalker
took his own life out of guilt a suicide
that the foundation expertly fabricated
to make their cover story airtight with
the loose end of Martin Sims taken care
of the true observation of SCP 3008
could begin a base set around the
perimeter of the mysterious Ikea kept a
24-hour watch on the building covering
all potential entrances and exits no
exploratory missions had yet been
approved by the foundation Ethics
Committee so they first wanted to
perform a week of external observation
to see if any of the store's anomalous
properties extended beyond the confines
of the building after a week of nothing
it appeared they did not a local site
director approved of the use of 20
disposable class D Personnel to explore
the interior of SCP 3008 the d-class
operatives would be split into four
squads of five men alpha bravo charlie
and Delta Squad each would be assigned a
different quadrant of the store and
would deliver information back to the
control team on site via a live audio
and video link three of the four teams
upon entering the store reported did
nothing out of the ordinary neither the
audio or video they were sending back
indicated anything different from a
standard IKEA store from the flat pack
wardrobes to the Swedish meatballs Team
Delta however suddenly began
experiencing a scrambled Audio and Video
Connection shortly after communication
with Team Delta dropped off entirely
they disappeared somewhere inside the
store and haven't been seen since with
one notable exception after The
Disappearance and the extraction of
teams Foundation researchers classified
SCP 3008 as uclid because its anomalous
properties were at least confined to the
interior of the store and even then
seemingly not the entire interior the
anomalous area within SCP 3008 became
known as SCP
38-1 and containment appeared to be 100%
secure there was no telling how many
people had already gone missing in the
store over the years but the
disappearances Must Be Stopped the
foundation maintained constant
surveillance around the perimeter of SCP
3008 but it appeared they could prevent
any further incidents by simply
preventing other civilians from
accessing the IKEA store Martin's
ravings about monsters were assumed to
just be the product of delirium until a
surviving member of Delta team suddenly
reappeared the date was November 3rd
2011 it was a cold night a few hours
after what would have been closing time
if the store were still active and 7
months after the extraction teams had
disappeared somewhere in the confines of
SCP 3008 there had been no anomalous
activity outside the store since the
perimeter was first secured and the
foundation researchers hadn't expected
that to change until the last surviving
member of Delta team came barging out of
the store's entrance startled field
operatives were amazed to see him again
but they were even more amazed to see
what was following him out of the store
repeating the same phrase the store is
now closed please exit the building
despite the fact that the entity chasing
the Delta team Survivor was wearing the
yellow shirt and blue pants of an Ikea
store employee the being definitely was
not human it was around 7 ft tall with
no visible face The Entity had grossly
extended limbs with each arm being
around 5 or 6 ft long and ending in a
huge oversized hand the whole process
was so sudden that the field agents
present at the perimeter weren't able to
save the Delta team Survivor as the
entity reached forward with his
freakishly long arms grabbed him and
twisted his head off like a child with a
doll the field operatives present Drew
their weapons and peppered The Entity
with bullets it would later be
classified as SCP 38-2 the being
appeared to collapse and die from the
physical trauma at which point it and
the body of the former Delta team
Survivor were taken for an autopsy by
Foundation researchers there were no
biological abnormalities of the body of
the Delta team Survivor so it did not
appear that the anomalous properties of
SCP
38-1 had any effect on the physiology of
its occupants he was not malnourished
despite being missing for months and the
contents of his stomach looked to be
half- digested food consistent with the
menu of a typical IKEA store restaurant
SCP 3008-2 on the other hand raised a
number of perplexing biological
questions the autopsy revealed that the
creature's clothes were actually part of
its body like an additional layer of
skin the creature lacked blood or any
kind of vascular system even stranger
The Entity didn't appear to have bones
or internal organs not even a brain or
nervous system it was a being made
entirely of skin all the way to its core
how it was able to move or even live for
that matter remains a mystery though
when you work for the SCP Foundation you
learned to accept that some things will
always remain unexplained one thing was
certain though Martin Sims was right
about monsters after the incident with
Delta team the foundation deemed that
sending man Explorations Into the Heart
of SCP 3008 was too much of a liability
and planned a series of drone-based
reconnaissance missions into the anomaly
the first of these drones experienced
connection issues and failed when
attempting to venture into the Ikea's
anomalous Zone however after a lengthy
period of trial and error the foundation
was able to establish a more secure
connection with its drones even went
deep into the SCP 38-1 anomalous Zone it
was only then that some of the most
extraordinary discoveries were made SCP
38-1 seemed to break the laws of spatial
reality as the area of the Ikea's
interior was at least an order of
magnitude larger than its exterior just
as Martin Sims had said it was bigger on
the inside but just how much bigger the
foundation has yet to find evidence of
any physical Terminators within the
store that might indicate SCP 38-1 has
an end point while an area of at least
10 km squared has been uncovered in SCP
38-1 it could in theory be infinite
laser Rangefinder tests which are
normally very reliable have only given
inconclusive results interestingly the
anomalous area doesn't have any clear
visual differences from the rest of the
IKEA store except that it extends
forever an individual trapped within the
confines of SCP 38-1 wouldn't even
realize they've entered an anomalous
zone until they tried to locate an exit
and leave at which point they'd find
they were already hopelessly lost the
geography of SCP 38-1 does at least
appear to be consistent so people
trapped with th are theoretically able
to retrace their steps and Escape if
they haven't already ventured too deep
according to data collected during the
Drone reconnaissance missions SCP 3008-2
of which there appear to be a vast
population would wander the stores
aimlessly during the day they are
unresponsive to the drone's presence and
did not appear to be aggressive while
the physical descriptions of these
creatures could vary slightly they all
follow the same overall trend clothes
consistent with an Ikea uniform no face
either seemingly Too Tall or too short
and limbs that are grossly out of
proportion with their bodies as the
foundation began sending drones deeper
into SCP 38-1 they found another
incredible Discovery there was an
unknown population of humans trapped
inside Ikea's anomalous Zone and these
people had used the IKEA furniture
around them to create entire settlements
and towns within the store there were
several of these towns all of which
seemed to cohabitate peacefully even
Foundation Personnel found this
development in their research to be
truly extraordinary since SCP 3008 was
first identified there have been only 14
civilian escapes some had been trapped
inside for months others had been in
there for years some far longer than
Martin's 3E sent while every one of
these escapes has eventually been
released back to their home after a
liberal application of amnestics and a
proper cover story has been devised the
foundation interviewed each of them
extensively first according to each of
these escapes the people trapped inside
the Ikea have built an entirely new
Society across the various settlements
contrary to the Lord of the Flies
expectations of a group of people
isolated and Afraid there is immense
cooperation between the trapped
civilians the food in the several Ikea
restaurants and SCP 38-1 mysteriously
replenishes while nobody's there so
there's no threat of starving and the
automatic turning on and off of the
lights forms as a rudimentary kind of
day and night cycle nighttime however is
when things get dangerous as the SCP
3008-2 entities which are known to the
people inside as the staff become
extremely hostile after dark a
aggressive hordes of the staff swarm the
settlements at night repeating this door
is now closed please exit the building
the civilians inside are usually able to
repel these attacks with minimal
casualties but the constant War of
Attrition slowly wears down those inside
the bodies of the creatures also need to
be removed from the area after each
attack as the presence of corpses or
even parts of corpses has been known to
heighten the ferocity of the next
night's attack during the day the staff
return to a docile and unresponsive
State though they'll still defend
themselves violently if anyone dares to
attack over the course of the interviews
with the 14 Escape East foundation
researchers were able to answer another
of their key questions how had so many
people gone missing in the store for so
long without being noticed but the
answer they received only raised many
more unsettling queries according to the
escapees there were people inside the
settlements that despite being otherwise
of entirely sound mind and standard
intelligence seemed to lack very common
knowledge that even a child should know
for example some of them weren't aware
of the International Space Station
orbiting the Earth or stranger still the
existence of the Statue of Liberty this
led the researchers to a frightening
conclusion SCP 38-1 may not only be an
access point of multiple Ikea stores in
our Dimension it could be connected to
Ikeas in every Dimension where Ikeas
exist while it only abducts a handful of
people from each store over an extended
period of time it suddenly becomes clear
how this SCP was able to trap so many
people without detection over such a
long period of time which in turn led to
an even more terrifying Revelation the
SCP Foundation made not have SCP 38-1 as
contained as they thought it might even
be tucked away in an Ikea store
somewhere near you just waiting for you
to visit after all there's always room
for one more it's a natural instinct in
many species to protect their young and
sometimes it's not just their own babies
but any young that look like them
regardless of your personal feelings on
humans earliest stage it is a scientific
fact that human babies are designed to
emphasize their own own adorable
helplessness to make sure that other
older humans take care of them a baby's
cry is an inherently distressing sound
and when we hear it some deep Primal
part of us feels the urge to comfort and
care for the child until the sound stops
but of course we're talking about the
world of the SCP Foundation here where
there are bunnies that can eat anything
teddy bears that might steal your organs
to make duplicates of themselves and
chocolate fountains filled with
trillions of murderous insects Nothing
Is What It Seems here and even the most
innocent and cute creatures may be
hiding A Deadly Secret SCP 734 being no
exception today we're talking about the
baby this anomaly proves that dangerous
things can come in small packages but
where others only saw misery and death
the SCP Foundation saw a certain
potential Our Story begins in the
maternity ward of a hospital in the USA
where every medical professional's worst
nightmare was unfolding an unknown but
incredibly fast acting flesh eating
pathogens seemed to be running rampant
across the hospital's population it
began when patients who weren't even
admitted for Dermatological issues
started complaining of severe itches and
extreme skin pain some nurses and
doctors in the Maternity Ward began to
experience similar symptoms as well as
one of the infants leading to a massive
quarantine effort while the initial
symptoms first appeared to be limited to
severe pain and discomfort on isolated
parts of the skin the condition of The
Afflicted soon escalated their skin
began to messily flake off as the cells
comprising it lost physical cohesion and
died it was a kind of strange anomalous
rot that seemed to work inwards first
destroying the Integrity of the outer
layer of skin and then cause further
disintegration to deeper parts of the
body once the skin had shut off the
pathogen would turn its attention to
what was lying beneath Against All Odds
the disease affected organs muscle
tissue the vascular system and even
bones nothing was spared the victim's
bodies would completely break down and
they would be dead within a few hours by
the time the pathogen had finished
ravaging its victims what was left
didn't even look human anymore not only
patients but doctors and nurses that had
been walking the wards mere hours before
were now little more than piles of human
tissue sitting in what had previously
been their hospital beds whatever this
was it seemed like the fastest
progressing infection in recorded
history Hospital staff and
administrators were terrified this
appeared to be an entirely new disease
with a mysterious form of transmission
and worst of all no cure they were even
more confused when several black vans
pulled up outside the hospital and
mysterious men in hazmat suits Spilled
Out and began setting up up a quarantine
Zone around the entire building whoever
these strange people were they
definitely weren't the CDC little did
the hospital Personnel know that this
was the group you'd never want showing
up and putting your location on lockdown
it was the SCP Foundation the infected
remains of the victims were taken away
for research purposes and the foundation
operatives immediately began conducting
debriefing interviews with Witnesses
they soon determined from a mix of
eyewitness accounts and Hospital
surveillance footage that everyone
infected with the mysterious pathogen
had all been in a particular section of
the Maternity Ward earlier in the day
and when the operatives investigated
this area they found another strange
detail an infant had no registered
mother present in the hospital the
foundation would later learn that this
was likely because the baby's mother was
the first victim of the deadly disease
after eliminating all other possible
options it seemed that the only
anomalous element that could have caused
all of this was the mysterious baby
though just how the mother even survived
carrying the baby to term was a mystery
in and of itself the baby was a
Caucasian male human infant between 7
and 8 months of age nothing appeared
outwardly anomalous about the child but
they could confirm that every single
victim of the anomalous pathogen had
come into physical contact with the
child earlier that day everyone who had
been at the hospital was given amnestic
treatment and the foundation cons
constructed plausible cover stories for
the deaths that had occurred that day
like so many others before it the child
was secured and Spirited Away to the
nearest applicable Foundation
containment site there it was
reclassified SCP 734 and finally the
real testing into what precisely this
infant was capable of could begin
physiologically SCP 734 appeared mostly
non anomalous the infant had above
average intelligence and physical
aptitude for a child his age but
otherwise showed no mutations or
abnormalities that would suggest a
Divergence from typical human biology
despite a vast array of test performed
by the foundation into essentially every
aspect of 734 biology they couldn't find
anything that hinted at the origin of
the mysterious pathogen but through some
trial and extremely costly error the
foundation was able to learn more about
how exactly the pathogen worked the only
Vector for transmission seemed to be
direct contact with the baby itself self
up to and including the fluids and
residues it leaves behind those affected
cannot transmit the anomalous flaking
effect to others meaning the risk of an
epidemic is relieving minimal but of
course accidents still happen as was
discovered when one agent misplaced her
Sympathy for the baby and decided to
remove her mask while interacting with
him her logic was that her masked face
might have caused the baby some kind of
distress and as long as she was only
coming into contact with him via her her
own gloved hands everything would be
fine but some dust particles were
floating in the air at the time and SCP
734 sneezed in her face the agent began
screaming in pain and recoiling from the
baby but it was already too late her
fate was sealed she was taken to the
infirmary and given sedatives so that
she could hopefully die in as little
pain as possible in roughly 72% of cases
amputation of the affected areas has
prevented the entire body from
succumbing to the anomalous effects of
SCP 734 but this isn't exactly feasible
where the point of contact is the
victim's head within hours the agent's
flesh had flaked off her face leaving
her looking like a red bloody skull a
few hours after that she didn't have a
head at all throughout the
disintegration process of this
unfortunate agent the foundation took
Grizzly photographs these photographs
are shown to anyone preparing to work on
the SCP 734 research project to teach
them a hard lesson on the importance of
adhering to proper safety protocols and
these protocols about how to deal with
the baby are incredibly tight given that
even incidental contact is often a death
sentence anyone entering the baby's
containment chamber needs to wear
contained atmosphere hazmat suits anyone
who makes physical contact with the baby
even when suited up is immediately
removed from the area and subject to
several hours of quarantine and
observation even inanimate objects that
have been inside the containment chamber
need to be thoroughly sterilized before
being removed given that even anomalous
children like SCP 734 have very delicate
needs a Handler is always standing by in
full Hazmat gear to take care of the
baby these handlers are rotated every
hour to maintain alertness and safety
these handlers feed and change SC SCP
734 regularly and sometimes even provide
toys that have been approved by the 05
Council the found Foundation has gone to
Great Lengths to keep SCP 734 alive and
comfortable because they believe that
SCP 734 could be an important asset for
them in the future or more specifically
they see great strategic value in SCP
734 blood as mentioned earlier contact
with any matter from SCP 734 triggers
its deadly anomalous effects including
bodily fluids like blood but unlike many
toxic pathogens in this case there is no
risk of the infection getting out of
control since the infected do not become
vectors for transmission because of this
the blood of SCP 734 can act as a
powerful weapon for both terminating
anomalies deemed unviable by the 05
Council and assassinating dangerous
people who belong to rival groups
contact with the blood would completely
destroy the target's body with no other
anomalous effects and no evidence of who
exactly conducted the hit SCP 734 has
been fitted with an AR material catheter
so that the foundation can collect large
quantities of blood from the anomalous
infant every single week for storage and
research but it isn't just the blood
that the foundation sees potential in
SCP 734 himself has scored incredibly
well on the aslinger Loyalty index the
test the foundation uses to judge the
Loyalty of potential applicants to the
foundation cause as s SCP 734 matures if
these scores remain consistent he will
likely be trained to become a Foundation
field agent in the future an agent
capable of killing someone with a touch
would needless to say be an asset to
certain covert missions that the
foundation would probably prefer to keep
off the books of course the SCP
Foundation recruiting certain compliant
anomalies to perform missions for them
is far from unprecedented the most
infamous of these is SCP
076 also known as AEL a supernatural
eternally resurrecting swordsman and
perhaps one of the finest Warriors who
who ever lived the foundation took note
of this and channeled his eternal thirst
for battle into working with his very
own mobile task force he could assist in
missions by taking out his blood lust on
enemy groups of interest and dangerous
anomalies however this ended up working
a little too well and led to disaster
Abel was so good at his job that he
burned through all of his allotted
Missions at astonishing speed left with
nothing more to do Abel got ansy which
led him to turning his murderous desires
on his fellow team members and then the
foundation as a whole it was an allout
Massacre before his colleagues were
finally able to kill him and return him
to containment the failure of this
initiative gave the very idea of letting
anomalies work for the foundation in the
field a bad name but since then things
have changed especially with the
establishment of MTF Alpha 9 AKA Last
Hope a new mobile task force formed
entirely of anomalous individuals and
their handlers these consist of somewhat
more stable anomalies such as ael's
counterpart SCP 073 also known as C Kane
cannot be harmed with any harm befalling
him simply being mirrored back on his
attacker and his vast array of knowledge
makes him an incredibly useful
intelligent asset another of the several
members of Last Hope is Iris also known
as SCP 105 much like Kane Iris not only
has anomalous powers that make her
immensely valuable for missions in the
field she's also compliant and capable
of listening to reason unlike Cain her
abilities include being able to actively
surveil and even interact with photos of
any location especially when taken with
her anomalous camera someday SCP 734
could count himself among other
anomalous Foundation agents like these
providing he continues to show promise
and doesn't develop a dislike of the
foundation as he ages since after all he
won't be a baby forever so if you ever
find yourself on the foundation's bad
side you have a good reason to be
paranoid you'll have no idea that one
day the man who's going to kill you will
approach and shake your hand with a
smile it won't be until later when you
feel that strange tingle on your palm
and feel the skin starting to flake away
that you'll realize you've been a dead
man walking for hours you've been
walking for days your body aches you're
dripping with sweat from The Heat Of The
Sun bearing down overhead and yet you're
wrapped up in layers upon layers of
clothing even your face is covered and
you're wearing thick black goggles so
that not a single centimeter of your
body is exposed your journey has been
long and you feel like you might die
from exhaustion or from overheating due
to these multiple layers of clothes but
dying is better than being exposed you
saw it happen when your entire team
changed the light cannot be trusted not
even for a fraction of a second it's
been like this for years you've learned
and survived through painful experience
many of those You Used To Know cannot
say the same you've been alone for so
long you might have given up all hope if
it wasn't for the distress signal coming
from a nearby SCP Foundation containment
facility site 46 any kind of survivors
would be better than nothing no matter
what kind of sorry shape they were in as
long as they were still human you find
your way to an opening in the side of a
mountain and slide into the cave hoping
you weren't spotted the whole world is
crawling with those things now you can't
let yourself be seen as you trudge down
the cave towards the entrance you see
what looks like a huge black snail Trail
splattered on the ground leading into
the facility you try to avoid it and
press on you don't even need a key card
to enter the door has been left a jar
the facility reeks of those things but
you can't see any of them you just hope
they've moved on and left some human
survivors in their wake the place looks
abandoned every step you take Echoes
through the empty Halls when you find
that the elevator's out you take the
stairs all the way down to level B5 ker
containment lucky for you it seems all
the cells are empty now the bors that
were kept inside of them have all long
since flown the coupe you keep following
that slimy black Trail until you find an
abandoned office there are no people
here anymore just a broken barricade
some empty medicine bottles and a bucket
that the people inside the office had
apparently been using as a toilet you
breathe a sigh of disappointment at
finding no one alive here but you're at
least relieved to be out of the sun you
can finally remove your jacket and head
wrap with your uncovered eyes you notice
that a nearby computer terminal is still
powered up you sit down at the desk and
turn on the monitor because of the
emergency procedures put into place in a
k class scenario like this safeguards no
longer apply you can access all the
information you need up to and including
finding out what actually happened in
the dull glow of a nearby emergency
light you see a dark shape slumping
through the halls in Shadow ens up then
exhale as it slithers off into an
adjoining Hall you're safe for now the
terminal has finally loaded and
authenticated your access you're staring
at the file for SD loocks proposal for
SCP 001 when day breaks it's the only
name you can give the apocalypse your
world is currently experiencing this is
one of the only anomalies in the entire
history of the SCP Foundation to be
given the apolon containment class
meaning containment is truly impossible
SCP 001 is the most dangerous enemy that
the foundation and planet earth has ever
faced it's always been the principle of
the SCP Foundation to battle in the dark
so that the civilian world can thrive in
the light but now the light has become
the enemy anyone exposed to any amount
of sunlight for even the briefest period
of time is subjected to the effects of
SCP 001 and those effects are Beyond
horrifying the SCP Foundation
administrator released an urgent memo
telling Foundation Personnel to make
their way to site 19 at all costs
because they need all the help they can
get those exposed to SCP 001 in the
process are no longer considered human
their new designation is SCP 001 d a
these new entities are to be avoided at
all costs but in case of emergencies the
administrator says it is permitted to
cut off parts of your transformed
comrades and eat them to avoid
starvation no attempt should be made to
kill them since you won't succeed you'll
just put yourself at risk when the sun
changed and became SCP 001 it instantly
affected 6.8 billion innocent people the
second the visible light touched them
whether it was from the Sun itself or
even reflected off the moon their bodies
liquefied melting like C wax into
puddles of living gelatinous slime this
effect isn't isolated to humans either
any biological entity exposed to
sunlight immediately underwent the same
irreversible melting process into SCP
001a and the horror had only just begun
people transformed into SCP 001a will
remain shades of their Former
Intelligence and personality they may
even try to will their new gooey Mass
into a a shape resembling their original
form however these individuals will lose
their sense of self if they come into
contact with other instances of SCP 001
d a when they come together 001a
instances will bond on a molecular level
waiting up into horrific giant blobs
with only one purpose integrating more
matter into their bodies that's why they
have to be avoided at all costs you
continue to search the computer terminal
for answers perhaps there was some kind
of contingency plan put in place for
this some way to reverse the effects or
at least escape the nightmare Earth has
become instead you find a series of
attachments linked to the SCP 001 file
detailing what seems to be the last days
of the people who barricaded themselves
in the facility most prominent among
these were researcher Dr Logan igata her
partner arri a security officer named
commander anad and a few others s Dr
igata had locked herself in the office
where she recorded her final messages to
the world in the first audio log Dr
igata and her companions seemed afraid
but hopeful that there may be some way
out of this situation Dr igata reported
that most of the workers at the facility
were transformed during the initial
event their melted bodies had fused
outside the facility and now they were
trying to bust their way back in the
defenses had held so far though and they
seemed confident they would hold long
enough for them to figure out a way to
escape this awful situation you open the
second attachment an incident report and
realized things may not have been as
hopeful as Dr igata L on she reported
hearing the huge mass of melted
creatures hammering on the door outside
again begging for them to come out and
experience the sun with them they wanted
desperately to add to their ever growing
biomass in order to experiment with what
exactly would happen they sent out one
of their few remaining DCL classes
wearing a full protective suit he didn't
last long the huge creature grabbed him
with tentacles made of reconstituted
Flesh it began ripping off his
protective suit as he screamed for Mercy
it was a monster made of dozens of
people and animals he could never
overpower it the second the Sun Touched
his skin he melted away and was absorbed
by the great Mass holding him in place
guns were ineffective against these SCP
001 super entities fire would do no good
it seemed that extremely low
temperatures were the only way to slow
the immense blobs down and even then not
permanently there was one ray of light
in the darkness the site director had a
secret tunnel underneath his office
connected to a tram that could hopefully
take them directly to site 19 without
risk of SCP 001 exposure it was a good
plan and by far the best best option
they had available to them but the best
plans often don't work in practice you
open the next Detachment on the terminal
this time it's a video feed you can
actually see Dr Logan igata and she
looks harrowed by what she's experienced
as it turns out while the others
including her partner Ari attempted to
escape through the tunnel something had
happened Dr igata heard Ari's voice over
her radio but there was something wrong
with it it was too low too guttural and
filled with gurgles SCP 001 had gotten
her she was changed the monster from
above had crawled in through the ceiling
it had taken them all of them and
converted them into something less than
human any hope of Escape now seemed gone
Ari told Dr igata that it would be fine
that it was such a bright beautiful
sunny day outside and she was wasting it
locked up inside that office she
tormented Dr igata with their shared
memories of picnics in the park on sunny
days in the past the monster with AR's
voice did everything it could to try to
convince Dr igata to give up and join
them but she wasn't ready to go just yet
you look away from the screen when you
hear a sound in the corner you see a
dark puddle of some unknown substance
and then some skeletal hands rising out
of it the hands are pulling themselves
out of the puddle followed by a skeletal
face covered in matted hair you you have
to stop yourself from screaming until a
flash from a nearby security light makes
the figure disappear it's a normal
puddle once again Your Mind is Playing
Tricks on you you open the next
attachment another video and see that Dr
ot's condition has deteriorated she
looked pale frantic and thin she was
using a knife to draw her own blood onto
a piece of bloodstained parchment
covered in strange symbols it got a
ranted about her Theory what if 001 took
the the minds and bodies of its victims
but not their souls through performing
some kind of Arcane blood ritual she
hoped to at least rescue and keep the
soul of Ari even if her mind and body
were lost you open the next attachment
it seemed that agata's ritual worked but
not in the way she hoped the Twisted
soul of Ari driven mad by SCP 001 had
taken over the file it begins corrupting
the text of the SCP 001 file into crazy
ranting about how feudal it is is to
fight it then cuts to an even more
frightening video feed Dr igata in her
sleep tossing and turning in a makeshift
bed in the corner of her office the
camera approaches her in first person
and lingers over her sleeping body an
oily skeletal hand reaches past the
camera and runs its fingers through Dr
ig's hair it's that exact same hand you
saw reaching out of that black puddle
earlier you must have seen AR's
lingering spirit with a lump in your
throat you open the next attachment and
watch the video you see Dr igata now
truly broken she'd been haunted by AR's
demonic spirit for a long time now and
it has clearly taken its toll she is
waving around a handgun while she speaks
she now believes there's only one way to
escape but not like this she doesn't
want the gun to draw attention to her
body she doesn't want to become part of
that mass even if she is dead she a
drawer on her desk she's recording at
and places the gun inside Dr igata then
apologizes to her loved ones who are
likely long since dead or assimilated
and turns off the recording for the last
time in that moment you realize there's
a single drawer in the desk in front of
you when you reach forward and open it
you see the same handgun Dr igata was
holding is laying inside you pick it up
and study it weighing your options
perhaps there truly is no no other way
out then you see an update on the file
one more attachment has been added while
you were studying the gun you feel your
heart pounding in your chest as you
reach forward and open the attachment
the text has been changed entirely the
file on
scp1 is now a poem an Ode to the Sun and
to ultimate togetherness then a video
file spontaneously opens itself on the
screen it's a video of you shot from
behind you see those oily skeletal hands
reaching for you in the dark just like
they did with Dr igata in that moment
you panic and fire the gun behind you
hoping to scare off the spirit instead
the sound of the gunshots attracts
something far worse the immense blob of
screaming melted flesh charges towards
the office you try to barricade the door
but it is not enough the flesh seeps and
bursts through and grabs you in its
meaty tentacles you scream and try to
escape but it won't save you nothing
will save you the flesh carries you
upstairs out through the empty Halls out
into the cave you can see the light in
the distance as the blob FES you towards
it you won't be alone for much longer in
fact you won't be alone ever again now
check out SCP 001 the Scarlet King and
SCP 001 which is the real 001 for more
deep dives into SCP 001 Mysteries and
lore